difficultés techniques avec avec l'arrêt
de la rediffusion et le début du nouveau
stream
mais tout ça est dernière nous bien
évidemment puisqu'on est live et on va
partir pour pour trois arrêts ni du
match le plus déséquilibré finalement de
la saison entre yann nepomniachi qui
n'est plus à présenter et elina
danielian qui a gagné attendait jeudi à
des travaux à côté de chez moi je vais
j'arrive une seconde et il est fort il
est fort il est de retour
il est revenu ça et on l'a fait on a
fait un geste technique
donc oui je vous disais le match le plus
déséquilibré a donc elina danielian
joueuses arménienne forte joueuse j'ai
envie de dire mais aux alentours de 24
50 face à yann nepomniachi aux alentours
de 2800 donc 350 points elo d'écart
entre entre les deux protagonistes ça
j'ai envie de dire et ça devrait être un
massacre alors est ce qu'on joue à des
jeux de qui marque le plus de points qui
fait le plus des fons
c'est un peu la question que j'ai envie
de poser au chat c'est un peu la
question que j'ai envie de poser à funky
flex on kiffe l'ex funky flex family et
jojo donc qu'ils sont qui disent coucou
qui sont les deux les deux personnes qui
sont là les deux les deux les deux
tontons qui sont là qui sont chauds qui
sont bouillants qui sont chaud patate
est donc la première partie qui voilà
qui a débuté ils sont royal charpentier
aussi qui a refait la charpente
il est là il fait la charpente du chat
donc le record est de 27 et demi à deux
ans et demi
moi ce que je vous propose les mecs ont
toutes en toute tranquillité en toute
simplicité
j'ai envie de dire on va en voir on va
on veut employer des mots on va on va
dire les mots les mots qu'il faut
plaisir on va être à fond pour yann pour
voir le plus grand massacre possible en
speech est ce qu'est ce que vous en
pensez l'élite
est ce que vous êtes pour le plus grand
massacre
après j'y crois pas trop dépôts qui va
tranquille c'est un match j'ai envie de
te dire c'est un match facile un idiot
le grand gourou c'est un match très
facile s'est jamais vu un match aussi
déséquilibré alors dépôt est ce que est
ce qu'on peut voir un peu sa queue de
cheval à il en queue de cheval il est là
on dirait un ninja ian les pouilles
nichi un genre de ninja russe c'est la
finale de quoi alors c'est pas une
finale c'est le premier tour du speech
est ce n'est pas une époque est sur un
siège de qualité gamer un lui aussi est
il à elena danielian qui en mode zoom de
niveau 1 et le petit échiquier derrière
donc c'est vrai qu'elle nous montre un
beau feront alors que yann il ya nous
montre un siège qualité gamer blanc qui
joue comme ça avec le noir comme ça cela
il a voulu faire un il a voulu faire un
style qu'il est très tranquille donc
cette partie se passe quoi on va se la
repasser
c'était une anglaise c'est 4 5 et 6 3 4
6 3 4 6 6 3
fouquet qu'adam ces deux théories
croquer et des 5 tours 8
[Musique]
bahia on avait un demi 1/2 oui je suis
étonné qu'il ya ne prenne autant son
temps mais ça et que c'est un peu le
match c'est le match le plus
déséquilibré de l'histoire honnêtement
ce serait aux pour faire un équivalent
un équivalent au foot c'est un paris
saint-germain carquefou quoi et encore
je suis pas très gentil pour carquefou
j'ai envie de dire là normalement c'est
un match de tennis s'est rogers fait des
lampes à feu dr quand même pas exagérer
mais c'est un marines ilitch contre
contre contre contre le numéro 1 de ton
club
quoi bon normalement numéro 20 numéro
cinq mondial compte numéro de 1503 donc
ça doit normalement être un massacre
absolue mais bon pour le moment ce n'est
pas encore le cas pour la partie qui
évolue bonjour à julos tard pourtant il
est tôt un petit et qui est bu un thé de
la qualité qui est vu par un dépôt qui
est tranquille va remettre le fouet f3
probablement je crois qu'à l'écrire
vieux 4 elena qui est solide peut-être
mettre une tour en à 8,1 pour venir
jouer là tu es là dessus il a fait tour
à cette c5
il faut trouver comment comment percer
la défense et vient qui avait qui
avaient bien défendu un en général
ouais il est pas là pour l'humilier je
suis d'accord avec avec with your daddy
j'ai l'impression qu'ils jouent vraiment
très tranquille et qui fait exprès de
pas jouer trop vite pour pas pour pas
être humiliant charles son conte à faire
un yann très correct
ariane qui cherchent pas l'humiliation
c'est tout à son honneur mais ça rend le
match - hareng honnêtement s'il tente
pas l'humiliation ça rend le match moins
amusant puis ce qui est quand même
marrant pour nous en tant que spectateur
c'est de voir des gros scores quoi y
réfléchit
honnêtement je suis sûr qu'il fait
exprès prendre son temps il pourrait
jouer très vite et juste boloss mais bon
c'est jamais forcément peut-être marrant
de jouer ce genre de match on va voir là
et peut-être du fou des cinq cavaliers
f3 mais là il le fait mais je pense
vraiment qu'il prend volontairement son
temps on l'a vu jouer plus vite contre
des joueurs du top niveau donc on peut
se dire que qui la joue tranquille tête
d'âne des quatre maintenant d'un rêve 6%
à prendre option h4 qu'il est tranquille
peut peut-être prendre aux 6es prendre
h4 vous prendre en bessette voilà
exactement il a son pion de plus mais le
roi jeu pour éviter torah et les noirs
qui tombe
première victoire pour les peaux way qui
à mon avis je joue alors on va pas dire
en dedans mais qui voilà qui jouent
vraiment tranquille c'est des petites
grimaces
il est vraiment tranquille ou mais je
pense ouais je pense pas qu'il allait
chercher le perfecto nettement ce qui
pourrait y pourrait essayer jouer pour
pour un trentenaire sera un beau score
30 0 quand même je vais vite contrat
nand nous dit l'autre jour bien sûr est
tout à fait donc il joue gagnant et qui
jouent un petit système tête sur des
seins qu'elle veut jouer b4 pour la d5
pour les noirs et c'est tout à fait
c'est tout à fait solide
elle joue avec des joues avec des six
est solide aussi on n'a pas lâché les
chevaux ouais non je pense je pense pas
honnêtement je pense pas qu'yves ou
l'humiliation
je me répète un peu mais il un joueur de
dender cut en plus
je pense qu'ils jouaient il va il va
jouer la gagne tranquille où on devrait
voir un score de type
20 à 4 ou quelque chose comme ça je pas
ce que vous en pensez
qu'est ce que les russes veulent
humilier les arméniens s'est pas
vraiment question nationalité c'est plus
c'est plus question que ouais y'a
vraiment vraiment vraiment un gros écart
et c'est pas assez jamais évident c'est
comme la cie jouer contre la championne
en fait puisque danielian elle a gagné
la compétition féminine du coup là il
rentre en compétition mixte
c'est vrai que même là c'est un peu
moche de faire 30 0 quoi ça fait genre
were au tournoi tu vois franchement ce
que je pense que l'epo va nous faire des
petites gaffes de la gaffe on est donc
là il va mettre la pression sur le pion
aux quatre un petit à petit met une tour
en 1 8
la dame en c6 il va venir visé ce pion
et daniil ans qui a déjà un prêt
problème et stockage ou tour e3 toi
parle vrai problème c'est pas vraiment
un grave mais c'est pas très agréable
c'est déjà un peu désagréable attendait
1 tour 8 comment est ce qu elle veut
défendre le pion
bon il est pas encore vraiment menacée
mais la tour en d1 qu'est ce qu'elle
fait en réalité elle tape elles tapent
sur des six mâts près d'am c6 qui prend
1,4 à est une vraie menace un don
qu'elle fait d'un tour trois dames ces
six tours 1 voilà perdus en tempo
on dit 30 peut-être pas mais zéro j'y
crois et n'oublie pas qu'elle aille à
l'ail allure à la cession de bullet qui
peut faire mal
la cession de bullet qui peut faire un
petit 10 01 suivant comme mon épaule est
l'une est en tout cas sur la cam il a
pas l'air d'être en mode je vais je vais
faire un gros score il a l'air d'être en
mode
thual en mode non rien de rien non je ne
regrette rien tu vois il est un peu il
ya un peu en mode comme ça tu vas genre
ni les semis blasé de la life non je pas
ce que vous en pensez mais leurs semis
blasé de la life il n'est pas en mode
déterminer je suis tout à la gorge
je vais t'arracher le coche pour et
launch est en chemin tu vois ça allait
plutôt en mode je me bois un petit et je
bois de la camomille je vais pioncer
après ouais non franchement il est en
mode en mode pourquoi un speech elle ça
dure trois heures et demie tu vois
il est en mode quoi il est en mode après
après le stream je passe à l'ehpad jeu
voir gary bass et plus ça ou alors ouais
je fais des parties pédagogique en
speechless speech est et dago gic
mais il a un petit coussin comme moi un
regard est ce qu'on n'aurait pas le même
siège de voir sérieux on a le même siège
sérieux je crois quelque chose qu'on a
le même siège
ouais non vraiment no fake les make no
fake crois qu'on a quasi le même ciel
regarde moi aussi j'ai le petit coussin
preuve du no fake
franchement moi aussi je me met à l'aise
comme lui avec le petit coussin sérieux
on est on est il né pourquoi on a si
pareil on est assis pareil les mecs on
sent qu'ils regardent la chaîne
complètement alors
il y en a le même classement que
dénoncent les 13-14 horaire est à peu
près fait même 12 donc là il a un pion
de +1 clairement il ya eu à 4 des pros à
4 donc c'était pour un peu casser la
structure mais au final pour le moment
c'est un pion qu'avait lieu 3 h 5 go qui
prend le contrôle du cavalier qui peut
plus jeter à l'endroit et il va
peut-être pouvoir switcher au moment
opportun sur le pion b2 aussi faisable
il peut aussi avoir l'idée jouer avec à
3 puis on prend à trois dames à 5 pour
se débarrasser des pions doublé et venir
récupérer un pion à 3 ou en c3 f4 c4
alors c'est quoi l'idée de ces quatre
ces matelas d'avancé 5 et de faire à
trois peut-être ouais c'est vrai c'est
vrai que là avec la caméra que
l'échiquier derrière je suis sûr que
l'échiquier a été rajoutée là pour pour
le stream les mecs un no fake que je
pense que avant et après le stream
il y aura plus d'échiquier à cet endroit
là donc il fait ça il fait dams et 5
pour à 3 et avoir un vrai pion de plus
f5 peut-être se faire tour 5 / cavalière
3.4 police fait retour 7 1 qui est
peut-être mieux ça évitera de se prendre
un thème pour un jour bon les blancs qui
ont un peu d' attaques allaient droit
enfin une pseudo attaque mais il ya
quand même un peu de jeu c'est vrai que
lecavalier un peu loin du roi est
peut-être un truc comme si on prend qui
on prend 1,5 et dames pranger 6e peut
arriver un jour il fait flasher 6 alors
choqué et dessins cac et prend des 5
malheureusement c'est dommage sur pions
pranger 6 il y avait faut prendre trois
donc tous rêvent 3 protège le cavalier
et prépare finalement tour g3 une tour
qui pourrait venir en g3 pour pour s'en
prendre aux rois écoutez j'ai envie de
dire pourquoi pas hein pourquoi pas
alors comment on réagit avec les noirs à
cette histoire là
est-ce qu'on fait roi h7 et on essaye
immédiatement de couper de couper court
à tout à tout problème sur le pion g6
donc comme ça sur re5 maintenant il ya
plus d'un an prend g6 donc c'est l'idée
droit h7 est peut-être cavaliers 17
cavaliers 5 pour venir s'en prendre à la
tour et colmater un peu tout ça est
intéressant maintenant revenir avec les
grandes pattes du cavalier peut-être
même vers détroit regard si lecavalier
il arrive en d3 les mecs ses droits du
pétrole
c'est le roi du pétrole il faudra un
jingle dallas en fait j'aime rajoute un
jingle dallas pour pour les prochains
stream quand il ya des rois du pétrole
au monde mais dallas ça peut être
marrant mais là c'est un roi du pétrole
non voilà il est il est parti le roi du
pétrole est là les mecs jr et la jr et
là attention attention les amis
cavaliers cinq attaques latour ya pas
tous rêvent cette cavale id3 ça peut
refaire un tempo il ya du fou j'essaie
aussi à du fou g5 et du fou fou g7
j'aime bien bon ça ça laisse tour f4 ou
g5 encore plus fort
bon bah ça à faire ouais palmarès de
tours f4 ma pièce de matour et et
emprises allez tout le temps emprise
quoi palmarès du coup j'ai envie de te
dire palmarès white cavaliers detroit
boom et surtout reprend 1,7 avec les
problèmes de échec
voilà deux victoires autant comme ça
c'est vrai kelina pourra dire j'ai perdu
les parties autant un gip a perdu la
position j'ai perdu autant dégage un
dépôt il a tellement l'air au bout de sa
vie de devoir jouer c'est fantastique
franchement il fait des petites têtes
genre ouais ça ça va être trois heures
de ça c'est quoi le c'est quoi le projet
il est là c'est quoi le projet tient il
se demande faut qu'il cesse poussé un
peu la barre pour pouvoir faire des
trucs un peu comme ça ce faire des
petites touches et de barbes peut-être
bon moi je peux pas parce que j'ai pas
la barbe longue mais c'est une barre un
peu plus longues il pourrait franchement
ce qui vous dit devrait se faire ça en
fait je réfléchis trop dernier ayant
ouais mais au moins elle parle pas elle
perd pas en un coup 1
il faudrait qu'elle suive les conseils
de ronds flex
toujours des bons complexe les conseils
les conseils de reflex à lait concentré
non mais la raison elle au moins elle
perd pas elle se fait pas à massacrer et
puis ça ça mange du temps à la pendule
bas mais c'est déjà un exploit qu'elle
perde qu'autant je joue soyons sérieux
un contre un joueur comme dépôt elle
peut juste faire ce match est vraiment
30,0 c'est vraiment possible
et c'est dans le domaine du possible
moi j'aurais peut-être refusé de jouer
le match blason danielian j'aurais dit
non je pars ça ne m'intéresse pas donc
les marques et ses deux cavaliers trois
peut-être qu'avec qui va venir en aide 5
non elle va pas tout perdre et poney
pour un moment donné il va un peu
ralentir le rythme elles vont gagner 2 3
c'est sûr nepos est pas un mec méchant
il n'a pas envie de il n'a pas envie de
ça quoi
mais il faut cinq à venir ouais non non
non franchement je pense qu'elles font
entre deux et quatre points sur le match
elle aurait joué contre nac anaqua il
aurait vraiment essayé de lui mettre 30
0 mais là n'est pas vraiment ça sera
donc là elle sacrifie pas de pions
pascal pion à deux ans prise donc c'est
bien joué
ouais tu prends un cours de trois heures
trente du copinage crois pas que tu
prennes un cours de 3 heures 30
je pense pas que ce soit un courses etc
franchement il ya trop d'écart de niveau
c c'est dur pendant une heure une demi
heure une heure ça va mais mais pendant
3h30 c'est dur donc à réaliser ces deux
il veut peut-être faire car il y eu 3 et
après peut-être joué pour d4
mais je pense que les noirs veulent
jouer pour des cinq hockey du bruit joue
pour f4 et peut-être le f5 même et g4 g5
et attaquer droit qu'il peut aussi jouer
pour l' attaquent à fond un genre qu'il
pourrait jouer pour repos du full attack
méfaits des petites têtes il fait il
fait j'ai pas compris c'est quoi ces
jeux 12 et c'est dur à faire ce qu'il
fait j'arrive pas à le faire
voilà peut-être plus de chance un tas
plus de chance
ouais de battre nadal à roland garros
dans le sens où nadal à roland garros il
peut enfin imagine il a un accident il
peut plus marcher ou tu allais un pied
dans le plâtre
en ce sens la série je sais pas je vois
pas dans quel monde arrive à jouer avec
gecas il va se faire plein non il se
passe quoi sur g4 il se passe échange
des dames
ok pourquoi pas wen et coupe perdre la
position et c'est vrai t'as raison donc
dame de et garde les dames et il veut
faire j'ai quatre h 4g saïb à une époque
il va envoyer le beau jeu il a mis le
pion f5
il va envoyer le bouge j'ai 4 h 4 nages
et 4 jouer il va jouer hkd g5 il va
attaquer le roi fou
prises en quatre reprises en quatre
et bien non l'idée c'est d'envoyer sur
le roi il a complètement fermé le centre
il vivait rue l'option de 4 1 qui est
bien protégé il verrouille les cases
noires puisque les noirs n'ont plus de
foot cases noires et il va juste envoyé
h4 g5 sans trop réfléchir ça lui
rappelle romain trois accusés qui on va
voir du sang aujourd'hui à écoute non
geslin
j'ai l'impression comme je disais juste
avant que ça va être tranquille où donc
un échec il ya deux écoles yassoi dame
e3 soit fou ou trois dons qui laisse le
pion c3 et il va envoyer deux partout
dave cavalli b 4-1 pour le moment qu'ils
gagneraient lecavalier avec la
découverte est sûr qu'à et des quatre
epr en d4 gamme c4 qui on peut déjà
faire dame prend puis on prend tout
reprend cavaillé prend un cahier b4 et
récupérer le pion mais c'est peut-être
pas assez puisque à g4 qui reste en
l'air à la fin comme ces quatre ça c'est
bien joué a joué assez bien danielian
quand même je trouve pour le moment je
trouve qu'elle réalise comme comme quand
pendant touché ce pitch est simple joue
vraiment bien c'est c'est vrai
donc
on a dîné en mode hashtag ton époux
avait pas mal c'est l' année peau qui
réfléchit un peu qui va rentrer là
dedans le cap et voilà qu'ils rentrent
exactement là dedans mais qui va perdre
le pion g4 bon qui rentre quand même
dans cette finale il va faire la fois
cette ouais il avait tout calculé suite
tout reprend ses 4 allée dans cette
partie là danielian elle peut elle peut
prendre son premier demi point et
s'accrocher et pau qui réfléchit je
trouve qu'il est pas si si dominant dans
les parties pour le moment ça reste ça
reste accroché là les noirs qui ont deux
pions plus alors elle va en reperdre un
voire deux mais elle peut elle peut
tenir là nul un dépôt qui a pas qui fait
pas mal hein pour le moment au risque
après ce parce que daniela on joue
vraiment bien ou une épaule est un peu
dans dedans il ya un peu des deux à mon
avis mais danielian qui avait déjà
montré qu'elle était très résistante
elle vite ce bien sur internet
donc en réalité surprenante au speech et
féminin elle était très surprenante
elle a gagné tous ses matches à risque
elle peut re créé la surprise
aujourd'hui peut-être pas peut-être pas
abuser quand même mes dépôts qui a l'air
un peu mécontent de ses coûts il a dû
rater un truc à tours à huit qui est
bien joué
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'elle vient pas
de jeter sur sur le fouet f2 on n'en
sait rien ces six donc et peut-être
caillou cette crise et 6 essayer de
faire tomber
voilà bien joué dans les speechs à st
elle a vraiment bien joué mais on sent
que ce sera dur en bullet un cavalier à
5 menace le foufou s'est vite seule case
a sûrement faire flouer fin j'imagine
pour recycler le fou et sans prendre
peut-être aux cavaliers s'est jouée sous
des seuils bien joué ça c'est pas sûr
qu'ils la gagnent tour ces trois ans ici
peut-être un petit coup de dent h4 je le
mettrais pas lâcher un petit coup droit
ou trois persos quoique roi ou trois ans
on peut se mettre sur la koala ranger
pour la tour cavaliers p3 roisel 6 et
maintenant il ya fou prend à 6 tours
prend 1,6 tour des trois rois bouge tout
reprend 17 roi prend 17 pays ces cinq et
prend ainsi ce n'est pas qui l'a pas vu
c'était une jolie combinaison peut la
voir ensemble fou prend ainsi store
points à 6 tours des trois-rois bouge
tout reprendre et c'est 3 prend 17 cas
ici cinq échecs
je pense que c'était forcé mais fait
tout rejet trois pays ces cinq ans ça
montre que les peaux et pas en grande
forme qui rate ça
mais bon comme toujours il faut prendre
son temps aux échecs niveau qui n'a pas
senti mon mail et va pour prendre g7 sur
échec il va perdre quatre tours c'est
cette hyper quatre rois bouge il ya food
et 5,6 probablement n'entoure à 6,6 à
tout repenser cicero apprend aux 4 c'est
fini tout de suite un pari réfléchi on
sait pas vraiment à quoi parce que ça
gagne juste du matériel ont deux coups
et elle n'avait pas vu et line 1 puisque
à la paperie move to reprend ses six
donc troisième victoire il est vraiment
il est vraiment facile de chez facile
donc ça fait 3-0 on revoit cette même
ouverture qui évoluent sur des cinq sets
joués avec b 4-1 je vais le montrer
c'est alors au lieu de rock l'idée sur
des cinq sets joués soit avec b4 pour
faire re 3 après et jouer c4 et avoir un
peu fixé le pion c7
donc on arrive dans une position
similaire à la partie précédente voire
même peut-être c'est une copie conforme
et donc il est noir c'était de faire
kelly celles ci souffrent ces cas pour
ces six tours huit touristes auront huit
étapes et sur l'option de 4 et les
blancs avaient eu du mal à taper sur des
six ont dit c'est bon on gagne autant
wef à toutes les positions ou le ou la
pendule tombe il est tout le temps
gagnant il est tout le temps gagnant il
n'y a pas une position il n'était pas
bien il joue très tranquille après c'est
un peu comme quand on fait les parties
pédagogique 1 c'est difficile de
massacrer à proprement dire il joue
juste tranquille et ce sera à peu près
le même massac qu'on verra entre naka et
d'oberhof je crois que c'est le match du
3 octobre que je ne commenterai pas du
coup puisque c'est le jour où je pars où
je pars en russie donc on voit cavaliers
ces cas donc il veut elle veut mettre la
pression sur le pion des 6 1 sur 34 à
apprendre des six est là du coup je me
pose la question est ce que b 5 et 1
coupe
après on peut se le garder sous le coude
un essai avec le cavalier peut rebondir
vers ou 3 et des 5
donc c'est pas sûr que bessin qui est un
bon coup préfère jouer 17 doit être plus
précis comme ça sur b cinq cavaliers là
on pourra peut-être faire cavalier b6
est colmatée
et l'on comprend un tour à 8 on imagine
tour à 8 maintenant pour mettre la
pression sur le pion à eux quatre ils
commencent par des cinq cavaliers 3 qui
est b6 du coup probablement et mon
interview sur youtube sort le 11 le 11
septembre dans une semaine
belle interview avec charles robin
interview de qualité comme ces six tours
à huit et on va mettre la pression sur
le pion de 4 donc à lui il aurait
peut-être pu faire des cinq dames c6
direct et sur qui a aidé 5 c'est quoi
son idée peut-être juste faire un coup
de recul avec le fou est sûr qu'à
rédiger 5 g touré 8 vêtements cavaliers
des cinq jouer après il ya une autre
école c'est de faire tout re 8 qui prend
effet si ce qui est propice pour se dire
que le pion aux 4 est dans le dur
c'est peut-être ça l'idée au final c'est
ce qui fait ça c'est intéressant les
mecs voyez quand je vous disais la
différence vous rappeler la le live
pédagogie que j'ai fait lundi et que
j'ai mis en replay hier où je disais que
parfois la différence quand on monte de
niveau c de ses deux fers menaces contre
menace qui fait que la menace est est
morte je sais pas si vous voyez de quoi
je parle ou pas ou pas du tout non
personne quelqu'un dans le chat est
maintenant que tu es tu vas faire fou g7
ou pas mais mais il ya un peu de cette
idée je sais pas si le chat si le chat
voit de quoi je parle j'ai pas compris
ce que tu as dit voilà on voit on
n'écoute pas comme ça c'est fait je
disais qu'il y avait une menace
éventuelle qu'ils étaient
qui était cavaliers pros f6 donc de
supprimer le fou qu'ils étaient très
forts des noirs mais du coup l'idée
données pose c'est à dire ok tu m'as
supprimer le fou mais en fait moi j'ai
une menace plus fort c'est que le pur
cas tu peux pas le sauver kg 5 tours 7
et sur f3 peut-être qu'ils avaient qui
avait des choses quoi qu'il ouvrait le
centre éclatant sur la colonne de était
très forte
donc du coup il a réussi à jouer ces
quatre une nouvelle fois mettre le cac
gagnant c'est ça qui va essayer d'avoir
le cavalier en d3 les amis et du coup le
cavalier en d3 il va être très fort
parce que c'est une pieuvre
mais il ya quand même ce cavalier des
cinq qui joue un peu mais bon il y aura
peut-être du f 5 un jour pour mettre à
mal le pion aux 4 et s'en prendre aux
cavaliers des cinq donc ça part et ça
paraît déjà intéressant mais bon c'est
pas si clair un des trois bien jouer
pour issue est compliqué puis on prend
donc elle a réussi à supprimer le pion
c4 alors elle réfléchit j'en ai quand
même joué apprend plutôt parce que
cavalier prend j'aime pas trop ce pion
c3 mais bon c'est vrai qu'elles menacent
les idées 4,7 pas idiot voilà ça prend
quand même et à 6 sur ac à jimani que je
veux faire cavalier à 4 et s'en prendre
aux pions c3 ça me parait ça me paraît
être l'idée du de la joueuse
j'en profite à revoir si jamais vous
êtes nouveau et que c'est la première
fois que vous tombez sur un scream
d'échec n'hésitez pas à venir dans le
chat à nous poser toutes vos questions
c'est vraiment l'occasion parce que
c'est pas le match le plus le plus serré
de l'histoire des échecs
il ya une grosse différence de niveau
entre les deux joueurs donc si vous avez
des questions en ce qui concerne les
échecs le jeu d'échec ce magnifique jeu
j'ai envie de dire
n'hésitez pas n'hésitez pas
à venir nous en faire part
donc on résiste à un burn-out en direct
2 qui où là il ya des caméras ou là les
caméras en switch et de côté
robert s voilà robert s qui voit là fait
il voulait arriver à l'écran robert
c'est la presse
allez on met des petits slips s dans le
dans le chat pour ceux qui l'on sait la
presse c'est la presse attend qu est ce
qui se passe là c'est quoi le délire
c'est la presse pour robert s c'est la
presse
c'est là est ce donc qui est scindée
livre à conseiller pour la tactique va
ya un vieux livre vert de bleu lors que
je recommande mais qui est plus
trouvable qui est plus édité mais qui
est trouvable donc y at il des parties
handicap de vente peter 2 et rui ça
existe ça existe c'est dire plus marrant
pour ce genre de match ce goût de pecker
méthodes et bien envoyé pas mal bon
alors à se remettre voir si à robert est
ce qui est revenu devrait revenir c'est
la s pour aubert est ce donc la position
qui a évolué pendant qu'on faisait nos
conneries et donc à l'oeuf ou g7 qui est
très fort avec le pion à sa rappelle une
partie je crois c'est fischer time and
off avec un fou en f3 est un pion à qui
avait filé à dame
oui tu peux tu peux peut-être tu peux
trouver d'autres blocs mais le vraiment
le vieux livre vert le vrai de brayer
plus trouvable donc les blancs qui vont
réussir à supprimer le pion à 5 mai au
prix de au prix d'une attaque sur le roi
mais ça va peut-être encore un comme
position
je sais pas pourquoi ça a fait
disparaître
voilà ça ils ont réapparu ils sont
revenus
wen en fait le truc c'est que le pion
des six est pas tombé attention la tour
e 8 népoty peut rater ce genre de choses
on l'a vu on l'a vu faire des gaffes à
saint louis des affaires gratuite
vraiment c'est la graisse et il a encore
gagné autant bon ça fait quatre
victoires à la pendule et ça va aller
qu'en s'empirant quand on arrive aux
trois plus un ça va être quoi le sait
quoi le sait quoi le délire il ya 4
heures déjà et ouais il ya 4 0 il ya 4 0
quatre victoires à la pendule quatre
victoires faciles dépôts qui en voit pas
comment il peut perdre une partie pour
le moment alors il ya peu jeu qui
demande kiev donc donc fc moi qui le dis
ce que tu penses que l'entraînement
tactique sur cs comme suffi pour
atteindre les 2000 fille d'où il faut
commencer à entamer les bouquins moi je
ferai des bouquins perso j'ai fait
l'open rapide à charger une perf à 1850
c'était mon premier tour n'aurait mais
c'est du rapide ça veut rien dire
faut pas s'enflammer peuvent poche qui
s'enflamme push qui s'enflamme push push
qu'on va bientôt retrouver courant dans
les tournois torse nu j'ai fait une perf
à 18,50 attention poche quand même un
ouais il faut faire gaffe aux perfs
ouais t'es trop chaud sérieux peuvent
les becs il faut lui mettre faut lui
faire l'iceberg est faux faut lui
envoyer un saut de un saut de glace
apple parce que là c'est ouais là ça me
paraît un peu non il ya un peu il va
alors là il est trop chaud au poignet un
extincteur voilà c'est ça donc attention
attention attention ouais c'est moi
attention s les sauverait attention
poche quand même ne pas te prendre pour
plus fort que tu ne l'aies on sent un
peu trop confiant j'ai quasiment envie
de faire deux parties contre push pour
le refroidir ouais ça sent le nos
matches mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
c'est pas floues un pas je suis quand
même assez fort et c'est sa poche qu'a
pété un plomb là c'est ça on est 1805
enfin on fait une perf à 1850 et on se
sent grand maître wade ans et ça il sent
fort non mais j'ai tout de suite compris
le délire est ce que j'ai besoin d'un
livre tactique je suis quand même déjà
fait une perf à 1850
oui bon ben ok enfin tout le monde fait
des perfs à 1850
j'ai envie de te dire c'est qu'ils ne
fait pas des perfs à 1850 dans le chatt
qua non mais sachez souvent des mecs qui
m'écrivent alors en cours ou quoi c'est
aller mais qu'il arrive ils disent il
dit ce genre ouais moi parce que souvent
les gens qui
qui sont chauds et qui veulent se faire
les sur choisille oui mais moi j'ai joué
en tournoi
voilà je jouais au moins à 2100 enfin en
tout cas j'ai fait déjà des perf à 2100
donc j'ai à peu près le niveau de 1100
ils sont là jouent à plus de 2000
tu as fait ouais c'est quoi ton des lots
make way je suis 17 80 mais je fais des
perfs au dessus de 1000 très
régulièrement je joue très bien ouais
mais pourquoi tu es 17 80 ouais mais en
fait non c'est parce que cette année
j'ai joué six tournois il ya deux
tournois j'étais vraiment en forme j'ai
perfé à 2000 2100 je joue à mon niveau
mais il ya 4 au tournoi j'avais le
boulot la semaine y avait les gamins
j'ai moins bien joué j'ai fait des perfs
à 15 cents mais selon les compte pas sur
la hat oublie donc attention peuvent
attention peuvent ne pas tomber dans le
syndrome jean-michel joueur d'échecs du
dimanche qui va t'expliquer qui l'a
battu en interclubs en 2004 un dimanche
il avait battu un maître fide à 2320
donc en fait il va t'expliquer ça et si
tu veux ça va être le point de début
pour t'expliquer qu en fait oui mais ils
jouent à 2002 donc voilà c'est à dire
qu'il va un peu baisser le niveau car il
n'ya pas dire 2003 parce qu'on a gagné
qu'une mais parce que voilà il ya 14 ans
dans un interclubs bon mec était bourré
en phase 1 et claudie pas mais bon le
mec était bourré il venait de faire
trois jours de soirée il a dormi trois
heures mais il a battu et donc ça en
fait si tu veux ça va des douaniers
toutes les perfs à 18 cents cette
victoire là en fait tu vas dédouaner la
défaite contre le 15 sans le gamin 15
cents à 13 ans qui est complètement nul
mais où il va dire ouais mais c'est un
gamin dont qui joue à 1900 en politique
un sens mais joue à 19 cents est ce que
ça en fait c est le point de départ pour
te dire qu'il est beaucoup plus fort que
ce qu'il est et des mecs comme ça on en
a tous dans nos clubs
non mais sérieux les mecs dont le chat
est ce que t'as pas un mec balance
balances ton c'est sans qui se prend
pour un 2000 j'ai envie de dire nouvelle
hashtag
balance sont 700 qui se prend pour un
2000 on en a tous dans nos clubs les
mecs on en a tous moi j'ai un mec dans
mon club
le mec se reconnaîtra pas parce qu'ils
s'en rendent même pas compte mais j'ai
un mec dans mon club il est 19 50
il m'apprend la life à chaque fois que
je le vois je vous jure il m'a dit ouais
mais moi je vais pas dire l'ouverture
silva se reconnaître peut-être ouais
j'ai déjà battu un grand maître à 25,50
avec sa jupe et ouais mais tu as battu
un grand maître à 25,50 mais quel est
ton score avec ton ouverture contre des
mecs de ton niveau et a joué combien de
mecs plus mieux que la secte white
combien tu t'es pris de douilles
parce qu'au final cité 19 50 et cuba des
25 50
il ya deux solutions non il ya trois
solutions c'est soit il ya les aliens
qui ton enlevé qui t'ont ramener sur
terre
solution numéro un donc c'est une
solution quand même assez qualitative
est vraiment vraisemblable solution
numéro 2 tu te fait enfler par la fidh
c'est avec à chaque fois qu'il voit tes
victoires non des fêtes troisième
solution en fait tu te fais défoncer
tout le week end
tu as gagné une partie dans ta life et
tu me l'as ressort à chaque fois que tu
vois après j'ai envie de te dire moi je
crois plutôt aux aliens mais ça vraiment
les mecs où on a tous dans notre club on
a tous dans nos clubs
des mecs comme ça mais dites moi dans le
chat dit quelques y ait des gens qui me
disent ah à la question de pages étaient
intéressantes j'ai répondu à la question
de pages on a on a tous des mecs comme
ça dans dans nos clubs on a tous des
mecs dans nos clubs qui sont qui sont
qui sont 700 mille sept cent mille neuf
cent est qui et qui se rajoute 300
points elo mais combien de fois tu vois
des mecs qui sont 1800 et qui dit ouais
mais moi je joue à 2000
non mais y en a plein donc c'est un
syndrome faut faire attention de pages
et pour la tactique non mais prend
prendre des livres de tactique prend le
livre le livre vert vert de bleu donc
à tout un vieux qui a battu en amical
mvl à beaucoup de jeunes sont vraiment
sous classe et lui dit sully fex tu
ferais partie de l'un d'entre eux le
hasard donc il est 16 100 is who is ou
non mais voilà c'était pour parler un
peu de ça et qu'il ya beaucoup de mecs
mais faut que j'écrive un livre ya aussi
les les livres de saba balog qui sont
pas mal pour la tactique qui en sortent
tous les ans tu as aussi les livres de
romain edouard sur sur les fautes
évitables échec il faut bien faire un
peu de trash talk les mecs là si on
trash talk plus en fait on perd l'esprit
les mecs mais tata plein de mecs comme
ça dans les clubs où là assez joli
saddam province est fou des 5es cavalli
pranger 6 en finesse et c'est une dame
dame de plus pour les peaux 5-0 les mecs
5-0 savané peau qui se balade n'est pas
à l'entraînement l'unss et c'est simple
alors
et bien sûr pages non plus chez donner
un bon conseil pêche c'est juste me
dis-je une perf à 1800 tueur est donc
j'avais envie de toi mais je dis ça pour
ton bien j'ai dit franchement
franchement peu de punch franchement je
te le dis franchement entre toi et moi
de 3 à moi ou de toi moi mais peut-être
que je fais de toi à moi je fais la
corde us à la fin de toi je me mets haut
niveau si tu veux des jeunes aujourd'hui
niveau orthographe tu jouer mais au
niveau
si tu veux donc toi ou plurielle de toi
à moi du coup peuvent franchement c'est
de la pédagogie
je t'ai fait franchement c'est c'est
très pédagogique
c'est très très pédagogique j'ai
vraiment voulu si tu veux t'en levé
cieux ce syndrome qui existe vraiment
dans les échecs français qui n'existe
pas en russie a d'ailleurs qui existe
pas en russie mais c'est vraiment très
typique des échecs français j'entends ça
tout le temps c'est de se surclasser de
200 points c'est à des mecs on est on
est une nation de mecs surclassé de 200
points tout en sachant qu'en france les
lots sont vraiment surclassé par rapport
aux pays de l'est
donc si tu veux c'est un truc de ouf
mais abaissé celle c'est le syndrome
jean-michel interclubs
c'est ça le truc donc ça faut vraiment
faut vraiment faire gaffe peut déjà se à
ce syndrome donc voilà il ya tu t'es
fait pédagogie fier c'était pour ton
bien ouais donc en fait c'est un mec qui
est surclassé qui se re surclasse quoi
c'est si tu veux tu avais les faits qui
secoue l'état le double effet kiss cool
serre que là c'est plus là c'était celle
à pacy fisherman's friend vous bouffier
ça allait pas si miss fisherman's friend
qui léman qui mangeait des fiches arms
and friends
ou personne salut kiev
je joue en ncaa de cette année des
conseils amuse toi fais toi plaisir
ouais fisherman's friend c'est un truc
plus tu en manges plus thème en fait
j'ai une période fisherman's friend
voilà faut le savoir et caveaux échec
on les repère moins bien que les autres
sports dans les autres sports c'est
michel ils ont du matos de folie et
jacques énormément de thunes dans le
matos ouais c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est
vrai aux échecs qui peuvent pas trop
claquer dans le matos c'est patrick des
échecs c'est typique français quand même
avec du footing et un toit de dimanche
qui a signé en ligue 1 ouais c'est pas
dieu dans le sud ont fait un peu ça mais
mais bon alors ouais et vous mangez des
caches ou par l'autre jour j'étais au
supermarché au casino tu achètes avec ma
femme je vais j'arrive à la caisse et là
qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce que je
vois je vois des caches où est ma femme
forcément les russes elle connaît pas
elle connaît pas les cachous géré
t'imagines le truc de ouf
tu tombes sur des études du cash ou quoi
c'est tout petit pas si j'adorais les
cachous faut absolument que j'en achète
l a jamais mangé des cachous de sa vie
c'était quoi déjà la pub du cash ou les
mecs c'est d'ailleurs là je suis en
train de lire sur puis on prend b5 dame
prend b5 ton reprend à cette dame prend
b2 et ça gagne papillon elle vous
n'aimez pas les cachous qui aimait les
cachous dans le chat la pince à linge si
je comprends bien ce que vous dites nous
non plus on comprend pas la pince à
linge c'est à dire que là c'est par
contre ton pseudo non plus on n'a pas
compris cela en est dans un monde où
plus personne ne se comprend t'as jamais
goûté les caches russules l'ifex c'est
ouf arrêter trop jeune pour ça ah les
jeunes ne connaissent pas les cachous
c'est abusé mais je suis tellement un
vieux arrêter les mecs fut tellement un
vieux
on l'a danielian elle est pas mal quand
même un le fou et bien et bien là
franchement elle peut faire un truc
danielian tête il doit faire h5 pour
quand même pas se prendre au jeu simple
lui-même s affaiblir sur blanc et away
ok il a 15 ans et connaît les cages
finance donc c'est vous qui connaissez
rien ça y est ça y est le chat le chat
connaît rien ça y est allé
ouais l'époque des tic tac les tic tac
ça existe encore ça ouais je crois que
ça existe fait tellement longtemps tu
pars en juin tic tac le piège ecoplus
qui tente mais témoin des échos plus
dans le chat les mecs n'en arrête ta
palois tente un piège aussi minable t'as
pas le droit de faire ça n'en arrête
arrête tombé six tours aussi c est qu
plus comme piège
est ce qu'il va réussir en placer une
non c'est pas passé c'était tellement
écho plus mais là elle va elle va quand
même la tenir danielian ya perron qu'il
y est tu peux pas perdre ça sérieux tu
peux perdre ça contre les po1
alors du coup d'amd 5 à 4 il va essayer
de faire à trois pour pour s'activer un
peu le fou roatan criqui percale
clairement ça allait changer
il va échanger les dames et sérieux je
pense à elle doit proposer nul il doit
accepter juste parce qu'il veut pas être
humiliant qua non vous en pensez quoi
les mecs
il doit juste accepté là non
sérieux cavalier e 4
voilà là il ya le mec de fortes mike qui
revient sérieux fortnight forte mytv
t'en a pas marre
nan mais franchement tram est si réussi
à faire f 5 x f6 food et 4 étoiles
encore capable de la gagner
allez faut ramener le quai en d2 et d3
peut-être tu penses à calais l'on tient
savez ce n'est pas moi j'espérais ne pas
la perdre quand même franchement
j'espère est pas la perdre et je suis 22
80 tu vois donc franchement ça me ferait
chier de la perte celle là même
maintenant après faut pas trop jouer
pour faire un nul non plus webb ellis
vaut beaucoup plus web un an blitz je
suis un peu chez un peu niveau
intermédiaire tu vois je vais être 25 50
27 60 g 200 points de plus d'un côté de
lewes mais je jouerai plus vite que
danielian c'est sûr
je n'aurai pas à me [ __ ] mal autant là
il va faire tourbe et 8 f 4k et b3
peut-être tuba danielian ou pas dans
blitz eux si je gagne pas je suis vert
ont normalement en large hausse quand
même 200 points différents sur chaise
comme c'est beaucoup quand même des
quatre mais bon lait mais joue bien on
se quitte chat ça joue vraiment bien
les arméniens qui sont assez bons dans
ces compétitions internet les armenian
eagle qui fait deux fois qu'il ya encore
deux ou trois fois qu'ils remportent
leur groupe de produits s league
la joueuse arménienne qui jouent
vraiment bien les speech est ce donc ils
sont assez bons
bon mais là j'ai l'impression qu'elle
s'est désorganisée maintenant il va se
prendre un échec
il fait quoi dépôt je pensais qu'ils
allaient faire tour b3 direct j'ai pas
trop compris cet échec honnêtement parce
que la ja paroisse f4 se passer quoi sur
la f4 attend les cheveux est un coup d'
or die welle dans cette écoute numéro un
de leur dire wife 4 bien sûr quand même
logique de montée droit monras g2
pourquoi pas ouais ça à faire nul il va
pas forcer si non c'est sean elle fait
un échec pour pas se rendre fou au 5
août ont changé trois fois au 5 janvier
il s'attendait à voir rien côté du camp
speech et ouais ça aurait pu être causé
new que ça aurait pu aussi être green in
a way prévoit que ceux-ci ne joue pas
mal je joue parfois clim tu peux trouver
mon le lien de ma chaîne en dessous mais
mais la cc on commente on commente un
événement les pommiers à chiquer numéro
cinq mondial contre danielian qui est
qui a gagné la compétition féminine
[Musique]
là il devrait faire annuler comme dépôt
non sérieux c'est moche si flag
sérieux je trouve ça moche pour avoir un
le truc c'est que s'il fait tout reprend
j'ai trois cavaliers 17 food et 6 c 5
mai en moi dans un match comme ça en
dominant autant je fais à gré par
honnêtement honnêtement je suis nul
honnêtement je ferais nul on n'est pas
là c'est pas une exécution quoi ok y'a
tours troyes et tours prend 2,4
maintenant mais ça marche peut-être pas
au la chanson pour le quatrième roi des
trois à la salle al hayya grosse
réussite pour danielian et c'est tant
mieux
ah il a pensé que ça gagner mais mais il
ya toujours le cas 3 et le droit des
trois rois f5 pour wave 3 pour protéger
la tour tour f8 frève six tours coeff si
je crois point m6 3 3 ou 4 donc on peut
pas prendre la pièce non elle a fait ses
6 non mais t'as pas le droit de faire ça
mais pourquoi tu as tu vois pas ça à mes
roi des 3c tempo ça se voit oh non c'est
étonnant quand même assez étonnant c'est
étonnant franchement c'est étonnant
d'avoir pas de pas avoir vu sa balle est
maintenant c'est perdu mais roy détroit
comment tu vois pas passer quand même
tempo normalement non non non oh là elle
était un coup elle avait de la réussite
partie interrompue pourquoi il ya un 7-0
aux non sérieux c'est dommage
non la sérieuse c'est dommage roi des
trois qui l'avait vu dans le tchat
non mais là on dit là une raison
d'insister nan sérieux nan sérieux n'en
donc un écran de pause est de retour en
est toujours là prêt à [ __ ] le souk et
tout le monde etc or dare jeu pas si
vous connaissez à mes poches qui l'avait
vu avec ses perfs à 18,50 n'était pas
venu me dire bonjour du cou et à
chartres où tu es venu me voir
surveillant récit c'est qu'il pouvait la
gagner et pas de raison de faire deux
pas de pain si c'était vrai mais non
m'étais arrêté pas là pour t'es pas là
pour mettre 14-0 quoi enfin y'a pas eu
c'est le matin est mais j'étais pas là
tous les matins aux siens mais des pas
vu l'après midi du coup j'ai mis 10
l'adoption non sérieusement c'est moche
sérieux c'est moche faut laisser un peu
des points des 2000 points comme
s'acquitteraient 9
on n'est pas là on n'est pas là pour
pour pour humilier quoi vous sur 25 02
fait nan mais là t'es pas là pour et
puis font pas au foot non plus
d'ailleurs
à un moment donné quand il ya trop de
mots rugby ou quoi qu'en ait trop
d'écart des foyers ils baissent un peu
le camp et puis quand il ya un gros
écart entre les entre les équipes qui
baissent un peu le ils baissent un peu
ils baissent un peu le pied quoi non
mais si tu mets 30,0 c'est quand même
fallait il aurait pu laisser là nul
quand même femme ça va tu peux laisser
une ou deux au passage quand elle a bien
défendu tu tu répètes les coûts
ça peut être un ça peut être un truc
quoi tu lève le pied quoi tu t'es pas
t'es pas là pour humilier les gens n'ont
plus voix on veut on veut une robe le
match qui reprend alors passer en mode
en autriche s
alors mais tu as il n'aurait pas dû
arrêter le temps à mon avis ils ont ils
ont arrêté le temps à mon avis fallait
pas arrêter tant faut laisser couler
faut qu'ils aient moins deux parties oui
c'est seulement vu faire l'aumône d'un
demi point qui serait humiliant
ah non elle méritait la partie les
mailles carrées swiss lite
à salalah mérité quand quand il ya eu
les coups à les cookies sont répétés
faire la méritais pas mais bon la
position était égale les coups répétés
celle écoulée plus logique
bon ok tu peux laisser un demi point
quoi tu as le droit tu peux
tu prends doit l'écraser par respect
ouais non mais sérieux les mecs ça
allait mais faut arrêter quoi faut être
un peu fou être un peu gentil parfois
sérieux parfois faut être un peu gentil
il faut faire preuve de mansuétude
c'est pas c'est pas icare ou en face
quoi elle t'a pas menacé de mort ni rien
à la fille tu peux tu peux être un peu
classe un peu sympa temps en temps ça
fait pas de mal
ça fait de mal à personne donc là le
double fiant kétou qui arrive
donc des trois fous des deux dames des
deux tours a des seins et après on voit
non sérieux et mme veil pour avoir pitié
non sérieux wen et pau qui se fait
clairement chez pierre ça c'est ça c'est
clair
car un peu macho parce que c'est une
femme et non mais c'est pas parce que
c'est une femme nommée arrête
non mais ça y est ça troll à dans le
chat les mecs a été faut arrêter un jour
c'est pas question de femmes ça aucun
rapport c'est justement toi d'ailleurs
qui est sexiste de penser que c'est que
c'est parce que c'est une femme fait
très attention d'ailleurs fait très
attention à ce que tu es en train de
lire flow physio c'est toi qui ramène ce
sujet là ça veut dire que c'est toi qui
pensent que c'est parce que c'est une
femme attention attention attention flow
physio je comprend d'où tu parles
c'est une question niveau pour être
chasse comme les faire jouer contre mais
je sais pas parce qu'ils ont eu cette
idée assez étrange de faire le speech
est féminin et après et après de faire
jouer le vainqueur du spi chess féminin
dans le speech est ce mix mais du coup
je sais pas si c'est du troll au final
c'est peut-être un troll duchess comme
ces gens rwe vient je te fais picorer un
peu des miettes tu vas gagner le speech
est féminin et après à tiens regarde non
sérieux de chaises comme là ils ont
abusé bavoirs que j'écrive arènes
chaplin stream
donc c'est plus une question niveau là
c'est plus ça c'est plus une question
niveau c'est comme si moi je me retrouve
à la place de danielian quoi ce serait
ferme à moi j'aurais refusé de jouer en
fait j'aurais dit ça ne m'intéresse pas
vrai le gain est au pourcentage de
victoires à perron s'est elle fait zéro
non sérieux j'aurais été un peu plus
être contre mais pose nantes 6 et 5 et
une idée ici peut-être pas dans
l'immédiat mais en général pour un peu
fixé la structure comme ça et c'est de
mettre le cavalier en d4 après
elle a fessé 5 des 5 et de 4 ok donc
directes 4
reveillere et nouvelle il a gagné 21 10
meyer mvl vous avez bien vu une fois
qu'ils avaient gagné le match et rôle et
il faisait g4 il faisait il est truquée
un peu marrant qua non mais là c'est sûr
que pour les pauses c'est pas évident
parce que s'il commence à faire ça on va
dire qu'il se fout de sa gueule
bon tu en prends dessins qu'ils essaient
tout reprendre un qui dévie la tour et
reprendre en d5 et du coup il ya une
attaque qui manque
f4 maintenant peut-être 5 qui va arriver
cavalier ces trois cavaliers eu deux
cahiers des quatre peut aussi avoir
décidé d'aller prendre le pion à 5 mais
perso j'aurais quand même ramené le
cavalier en jeu en premier
oui 5 il peut aussi aller faire dame ces
trois dames prend à 5,1 à tout moment
donc après il vaut mieux perdre 15 0 en
ayant joué contre l'epo qui n'a rien
donné plutôt que de perdre 15 5 en ayant
mérité les partis juste par pitié bref
mais non mais c'est pas deux qui te
donne des points mais c'est juste là la
position il pouvait juste répéter faire
annuler bon d'un autre côté elle aurait
pu trouver roi des trois aussi c'était
quand même assez évident et c'est fou de
ne pas avoir vu c'est ça qui est un peu
étonnant c'est que tu as l'impression
qu'elle rate rien pendant longtemps et
parfois après elles donnent elles
donnent les parties en un coup à faire
dame prend 1,5 au prochain ketura 8 est
jouable mais bon tellement moche pour
peut-être qu'il faut faire tour à 8 ans
ouais normal le temps je crois que c'est
parce qu'elle a vraiment du mal à jouer
vite
enfin le livre n'est pas là pour tout et
pour tout gagné puis c'est tout et ouais
non mais c'est sur une petit des petites
danses
tours en d4 c'est choisir un sac
poubelle qui tient de refermer bien
jouer ludwig non sans un petit côté
ninja est là il va prendre non non il
fait sa petite danse il chante sa
musique qui va pas l'air d'être terrible
peut-être faire du hasch trois cavaliers
g4 attention un cavalier aussi ce qui
arrive
il peut faire h trois cavaliers ou 6/4
et les g4 et menacera cavaliers f6
fourchette
d'un autre côté sûr qu'elle va lui aussi
se tait t'avoir x h 3à je vois bien
cavaliers j'ai quatre griefs 6 quand
même pour faire une triplette
allez c'est fini car il y avait six qui
avait pris huit mois il prend le temps
mais à même à cinq qui tombe après il
continue à danser
il va peut-être prendre à 5 me prend son
temps il joue pas si vite
on apprend à 5
la finale elle est archi gagnante un ca
à faire 7-0 les mecs
cet air à prendre ces 7 est peut-être
temps d'abandonner la quand même un
petit coup de foisches 3 o6 ça fait de
mal à personne
et merci a dream dream theater à
chercher qui s'est abonné avec switch
prime merci tonton belle abonnement bien
jouer tonton 7-0 les mecs hikaru contre
n'est pas à la trompe of ce qui est vrai
mais il joue la vente avec ggf ça sent
pas très bon voir comment il joue c'est
ce qui va faire 25 c 5,6 à ses six plus
tôt je rappelle plus la théorie
là-dessus
les peaux qui essaye de se rappeler
aussi
donc on peut on peut on peut faire une
adoption quand même maintenant on a
trois points l'adoption non mais ces
ouvertures là elles sont très mauvaises
en fait maintenant quand on vous sait
trompeau après fou j'ai cinq dessins
qu'on joue plutôt cavaliers d2 pour eux
trois ces trois jeux plutôt comme ça
maintenant
bon mais là ça va les blancs ont
peut-être obtenu un truc correct
donc allez faut qu'elle continue à jouer
vite peut-être que c'est là que c'est là
qu'est son salut
droit au sé donc c'est pas très
dérangeant ici de boucher le fou parce
que rêve 5-fu g7 avec les blancs c'est
dur de toucher 1 puisque les noirs ont
sacré masse de pions là il n'y a pas de
fous de cases noires ou g7 à part
peut-être 5b 6b cette tour des 8es à
terme c'est réussi à développer ces
pièces correctement il va jouer sur la
peur de fou n'est pas et tu t'en sedan
se danse cette chanson qui te plaît
c'est quand ça oui j'essaye de chanter
ce qui chante quoi je me dis je dois
chanter un truc de merde comme ça saleh
à brumeux
elle a quand même battu line of art and
square dans un match captivant plus tôt
cette année il ne faudrait surtout pas
croire que c'est n'importe qui
évidemment pas du niveau de népoty des
slops ouais voilà c'est c'est ce à quoi
l'a battu l'as haguenau qui était en
petite forme quoi d'ailleurs mais il
faut ensuite salé tonton c'est très
pédagogique car là il fait de la
pédagogie dépôt en fait le fou s'est
vite il n'est pas si mal placé le
problème du fou ces huit c'est que la
tour peut pas intervenir en jeu donc il
a fait un plan très classique fou 17
retour des 8 on remet le fou ans et huit
sur sa case de départ ça c'est un truc
que vous verrez assez souvent 1
bon là il un peu resserré arrive à finir
par en perdre une
il reste combien temps dans le 5 + 1 il
reste 15 minutes
pourquoi le fruit bien placé sur
quelques asie serait mieux en fait en 17
me fait rien en u18
il est pourri ans et huit mois il
protège le pion ça va quoi
eye for now tv en sueur attend il n'y a
pas un truc avec 5,4 ici s'est passé
quoi ah oui ok et cava lieu de je
pensais e5 est attaquée lecavalier après
mais à qu'avait lieu 2,4 fou j'ai deux
cavaliers de protège n'était pas là hier
vont mv elle a fait quoi mvl qui a
dominé de la tête et des épaules
donc
il ya eu un petit moment de difficulté
au début il était mené 5 1 et puis après
il a marché sur le joueur chinois
la muraille de chine qui s'est fait
piétiner par un colosse en trois lettres
coll du coup non mvl en fait le mot colo
ce n'était pas en trois lettres en fait
c'est un col haut c'est donc même belle
qui est un colosse mais en trois lettres
quoi sais c'est pas le mot colle au ski
en trois lettres
c'est enfin voila c'est important de le
préciser ce cas des gens le chat qui
peuvent qui peuvent ne pas comprendre
par avec qui j'aurai pas dominante
orwell savasem vld n'est qu'un
tranquille
franchement il a joué tranquille
annuelle 1 sans forcer tu as était du
petit mvl s'était lui-même vl tranquille
ou quoi ouais les blancs sont pas malins
les plans sont pas mal dans cette partie
n'est pas qu'ils souffrent alors ques
les sauts dans le chat de chester qui
vous écris ce match n'est pas le plus
intéressant be right back wesley so qui
a des avis très clivant j'ai envie de
dire angoisse les sauts qui te lâches
des infos c'est pas le match le plus
important intéressant à il prend des
risques wesley les avis si tranchée ça
pourrait lui coûter cher
c'est très clivant il est pas pleutre
avec un avis comme ça
ouais c'est un rebelle non mais là cette
partie elle peut faire quelque chose
basso qui naquit n'a pas peur qui n'a
peur de rien quand même jusqu'à bien que
les opinions tranchées c'est que ça
relance le débat léodagan léodagan
meilleur personnage ever de série bon il
est mal les pauvres ce que le fouet f3
il t'a bien là et les noirs qui ont pas
trop d' espaces dont qui s'activent sur
fou prend 1,5 à tour a chuté elle purge
de en sueur peut-être rachat est sûre h4
la frange et 3 évidemment tête jafar
revenir colmater avec lecavalier mais
c'est vrai que ça va être dur de
progresser pour les blancs
donc je suis en pirate c'est ça les deux
sont hors champ là les deux savent pas
cadré une caméra
je sais par l'acea on se dirige vers une
nouvelle défaite
peut-être juste protéger un peu et puis
je croyais pas partir en d6 tout à
l'heure en fait allé [ __ ] en c3 pardon
enfin jouer avec anne frank et prend
d'avoir ok 2 h 4 1 4 contre angers trois
pions prend et elle veut b5
salut louga 68
non mais là on vous le 10 01 min et v1
c'est en fait la sicile à une nul ou une
victoire de danielian c'est la cata ça
tue tout intérêt au match donc
et s'il ya beaucoup de top 10 qui
strient mbaya mvl hikaru né peut donc
c'est en fait déjà 3 bref auquel la
perdre celle là sinon ça tu l'intérêt du
match
donc est ce qui peut prendre une fois
effet retour ces huit essayé d'encaisser
ce pion autour des 8 même encore plus
fort peut-être mais il ya peut-être tour
ces deux ici mais ton et si c'est bien
joué il ya pas tour à 6
il va pouvoir encaisser le pion nepos
crime pas échec non666 script d échec
donc tour ces quatre peut-être et après
cavaliers des 5 et ça va jouer quoi il
ya un pion plus maintenant pour les
peaux il n'y a plus qu'une seconde pour
danielian donc on devrait arriver à 8 0
est-ce qu'il est bien ouais ça va il est
sympa
paris à faire peut-être je peux pas
faire tomber kadhafi veut garder les
tours et 5 c'est bien joué et peut-être
pour eux quatre ces cinq tours ces 2
août tous fous ces cinq d'abord voilà il
regagne autant et donc ça fait 8 points
ça fait 8 0 allez on n'est plus qu'à
deux points de l'adoption les mecs
encore deux victoires et ça le fait il
fait des stream en russe pour le coup
n'est pas bon il fait ce crime dans sa
langue j'ai envie de dire mais bon
streamer d'enjeu pour les gens qui sont
russophones je recommande
en tout cas il a un il a une jolie
sienne il un joli siège je trouve dépôt
donc
mais clairement il doit s'ennuyer un cc
long c'est long pour pour lui on va ces
genres de ce mythe arrache avec
peut-être une structure de pions isolé
qui arrive n'est peut-être foulée 2 je
sais pas s'il a un meilleur siège que
moi j'en sais rien mais en tout cas il a
le petit coussin au même endroit et on a
on a le même siège en fait j'ai envie de
dire on est frères de sièges
donc c'est normal aussi que je sois pour
les peaux dans ce match retour c'est un
cavalier à 4 c 5 ici faut viser la casse
ces cinq peut être intéressant faire
gaffe à carrer lieu 4
attention à ça là il ya un bon coup à
trouver pour les blancs mon avis ce que
dan détroit et un coup tête d'âne 17
il fait h3 j'aime bien prophylactique tu
perds tu conseilles toi pour te commencé
à apprendre le russe franchement prendre
des cours et trouver une copine j'ai
envie de dire c'est un peu la recette
miracle foot est roi
ok avec dam des trois était pas possible
donc il joue contre un pion isolé donc
il faut des trois quarts a lieu de très
bons plans d'après vlad dont 44 logique
et karen f4
donc surtout préemption prend on change
de structure dont on contrôle bien la
casse des cadres donc ça va el cavaliere
f4 bien placé il tape sur des 5es sur
six cas va les prendre aussi si on prend
ici c'est toujours bien pour les blancs
dans ce truc là et tout reprend aussi ce
ça dépend mais normalement ça va aussi
donc là c'est un peu chaud pour pour les
noirs je me demande si on peut faire
flouer f5 et x 7 pour essayer de menaces
et du cavalier prend f 2000 pour
assurant mettre un cavalier en des
quatre cavaliers prend on n'aura pas le
temps il nous manque un tempo la tête
ont fait foi cette direct et sur
cavaliers prend aussi ce tour prend 2,6
et on joue un peu pour cavaler prend un
f2 et pour des quatre mais j'aime pas
trop jambes sont que les blancs sont
mieux mais tu n'es val-d or die ouais
c'est ça les blancs sont déjà mieux là à
ok mais faut prendre quatre points f4 ça
va pas aller ça
donc
c'est un rist est pas cool de faire
jouer un des joueurs les plus forts
rapides contres est un joueur qui a 500
lots de moins et joueurs réputés plus
lent ouais c'est faux on veut voir
l'adoption les mecs un mois je veux voir
une adoption
ouais après la villa il veut faire g3
est fou j'ai deux je pense mal à vouloir
faire cavalier décade pour couper
il le fait
est ce que tu as comme a fait ça pour
montrer que les femmes sont nulles que
même la plus forte se fait démonter
contre un homme non je crois pas je
crois que voulait avoir une femme dans
le truc mais après c'était peut-être pas
très opportun your way it is et la
première fois je regarde un stream
d'échec c'est plaisant de voir les
strates et que les explique même si je
comprends pas trop car je suis un petit
joueur occasionnel sur un échiquier
maison bah écoute bienvenue à toi ie8
n'hésite pas à follow la chaîne en étant
un petit coeur ici tu peux aussi follow
ma chaîne perso tu peux trouver juste en
dessous et la chaîne aussi à 2m mvl
chess qui est numéro 1 français numéro
six mondial du coup ok il faut qu'elle
joue continue à jouer actif avec les
noirs de toute façon à 5 c'est bien joué
ça je pensais il faut il faut s'activer
il faut faire des trucs mais à 5 baies 5
du coup elle fou qui va arriver en d4 et
et les blancs qui vont avoir les bonnes
pièces blanches sur un petit plus mais
c'est pas forcément mort tout cas la
bonne nouvelle pour danielian c'est que
c'est que c'est la dernière partie de la
cadence donc le calvaire une partie du
calvaire sera déjà sera déjà derrière
elle et elle peut la perdre ouais non
mais pas très bien là avec les noirs le
pion d'à côté normalement elle devrait
la perdre elle est mal autant sur fou
prend des quatre j'imagine qui a tout
repensé intermédiaire des villes adam
aidé à me prends des cats et surtout
prend b6 tour prend d un tour condéens
et quoique il n'y a pas un et non il n'y
a pas de cahier c3 puisque le fou
protège hockey faudra voir cette
variante ce que ça donne je pensais à
première vue qui avait ça et ça mais il
ya le faut afin qu'ils veillent au grain
il a fait ça me prend des quatre quand
même puisque toute façon la finale avec
le fonds en d4 allait pas mal c'est la
même histoire à l'époque est dans le dur
hein mais il est peut-être entrer ya peu
un de des états unis aussi les peut-être
un peu dans le jet lag encore les poké 1
qui sera long un peu sur son siège et
réfléchi une seconde d'un crémant donc
c'est pour ça qu'elle tombe aussi un
hockey ici c'est peut-être bien jouer
avec les finales de pièces mineurs sont
peut-être pas si mauvaise donc
fière d'être dans le dur là je sais pas
quoi elle réfléchit t'as pas du tout
envie de faire tout reprend je pense
quoi que je pensais vraiment qu'elle
ferait cavalier prend c'est d'échanger
plus de pièces que là mais bon il aurait
pas échanger les tours jusque là le truc
c'est que les fours ils tiennent bien
les colonnes et maintenant il va faire
gk3 g2 3g 3g 5 il va faire jouer ce côté
là voilà c'est exactement ce qui se
passe
le roi qui est coupé de caillan c4 mais
sa menace rien d'avoir monté le roi
juste quand j'ai 3 et après h4 g5 du cou
de taureau ne se mange pas de pain a
maintenant elle veut échanger les tours
auxquels avantage c'est que vous prend
prises et fougue et si ça fait une foule
couleurs opposées
on l'a poussé cinq échecs très
clairement sa force 3 au 8 mais fou
prend ses 4es jamais jouable parce que
c'est nul automatique
je suis étonnée qu'elle est parfaite
ok on va faire un petit poucet cinq
échecs food et quatre non
elle va bouger ici c'est peut-être ça
marche pas je pensais fou j'ai ici ce
fou fou à vii fous ces cinq meilleurs au
1 800 qu'est maintenant fou g6 fouilles
8 pouces et 5 3 17 et f5 peut-être
houphouet f5 maintenant bruit n'a pas
fait faux f5 échec on sait pas mais
voilà il a réussi à faire le plan à
mettre le foin f8 à taper les pions et
ça fait 9 0 ça fait neuf there c'est un
gros score quand même 9 vers les mecs un
très gros score en faveur de yann bat
daniela la suède elle a su et
honnêtement elle a su est alors on va
partir vers une pause 10-3 si j'ai la
bonne musique
ce que j'ai pas le retour du sont dites
moi si c'est la bonne musique
[Musique]
dans le chat
on va faire une petite pause
[Musique]
vous
à
[Musique]
les mecs on va repartir on va repartir
pour j'ai envie de dire la partie la
plus intéressante du match jusqu'à
maintenant la partie du 10 0 la partie
de l'adoption
donc là c'est vraiment le moment qu'on
attendait depuis tout à l'heure on vient
de passer une heure et demie à voir né
peut gagner sans grande difficulté et
c'est maintenant que néo pop euh ben
[Musique]
on gagne encore une de plus j'ai envie
de dire et fr fr le 10 0 donc ce serait
marrant de voir une petite adoption dans
ce match c'est quand même rare les 10 0
et ça fait toujours plaisir à voir
ça peut ça peut être ça peut être
maintenant et donc la partie la partie
qui commence et avec des quatre alors
comment est ce que les pauvres à réagir
il réfléchit pour le moment et il a des
petits problèmes de connexion mais la
même sans connexion à mon avis peu il
peut y aller donc ça repart pour une
trompe offs qui avait pas mal marché
pour danielian sa rejoue la même
variante qui est plutôt marché pour
danielian donc née peau qui change pas
son fusil d épaule
peut-être qu'il changerait un peu plus
tard allez on espère on espère on espère
on espère en voir 10 d'affilée c'est
quand même rarissime
tout à l'heure ils n'étaient pas très
bien elle n'avait pas réussi finalement
à lci s'est est pris à trois b 4 c 5 qui
est qu'il y avait qui avait pris
beaucoup d'espacé mille cavaliers à
seaska et ses seins qui s'était fait
chasser cette fois il a pris directement
du fou allez on va on va voir jusqu'où
ça va à 3 à 5 ans donc ils se laissent
pas il se laisse pas dominer comme tout
à l'heure il n'est ce pas l'espace aux
blancs et peut-être même un coup comme à
quatre on va pouvoir être possible un
jour
attention vraiment y'a peut-être fou d
un fou prend à 4 mais né pauvre voilà
qui joue b6 qui va préparer fou à 6
tours c8 il va mettre la pression sur
sur le pion sur le pion c4 pour le
moment dernier lyon qui tient autant
mais qui réfléchit un petit peu
tu as fait ce qu'il peut avoir une
remontée la wii en cas de déconnexion
ouais il ya pour le moment il ya encore
10 20 il peut y perdre et en cas de
déconnexion il se ferait vraiment est
allé là
donc vous avez cinq tours c8 qui arrive
vous bessette tour ses huit autour des 8
pourrait changer ça va jouer la petite
finale daniela ou qui jouent un peu plus
vite donc ça c'est la bonne nouvelle
pour elle peut-être un coup comme f5
aussi un fort à faire gaffe menacera f4
mais mon ouvrage et 3 de toute façon h5
du coup peut-être avec des idées de h4
tour des menaces tour 17
donc il va falloir faire un petit tour
des huit ici quand même je pense à moins
que né pauvre donner une pièce dans la
tour des huit jouer il prend son temps
pour le moment cavalia 4 bien joué elle
s'en prend aux fumées cavaliers prend
ses cinq qui ont france et 5 ce sera pas
si grave
structurellement bon à la pression doit
être plus ou moins égaler ce que scion h
4 est vraiment bien placé on ne sait pas
qui a et d4
donc
qu'ils allaient prendre des 4 comprend
food et 6
il s'en prend aux pions options options
h2 donc sur qui les prend vie si tu veux
fou prend h2 et après éventuellement
faire fou j'ai trois faut être assez
bien jeu il n'a pas pris le dessus y
signer pour un je pense même que ça doit
être sensiblement égal enfin pas claire
pour un jeu qui prend b6 et sur tourbe
et 8 passes et 5 donc fou ces sept
cavaliers à quatre leur tour ouais ça
m'a pas l'air d'être est encore que il
ya du tour g3 qui rentrent donc à mon
avis ça peut se tenir avec les blancs
cette histoire hein elle est bien au
temps et joue beaucoup plus vite
5 d'accord ils contrôlent les cases
blanches et notamment cavalier e 4 c 5
l'option qui part qu'est-ce qui va y
avoir il va voir h3 il va y avoir quoi
moi je trouve la position blanche
complètement corrects a ripé avoir du d5
peut pas faire juste des cinq ici à tour
âge
ok tourage droite roya fouet f4 échec
mais tourache de roy j droit 1-1 et sur
fougères et trois rois d un mois ici en
premier il se passe quoi sur fouet
quatre tours à deux tours prend b2 ok
faut être quatre tours des trois tours à
deux rois f3 elle fait tour ces deux du
coup oui c'est pas mal aussi
torah de roi des trois tours 3 échecs
d'accord peut partir soit en d1 soit en
f2 elle par un des mains autour des 3
c'est le coup critique et il y a
cavalier b5 et sur fouet trois échecs à
roye eu deux écoutez ça a l'air d'aller
pour les blancs qui tiennent bien
entourage croit mon entourage de tours
france et 2 elle protège mais alors là
et ce qu'ils valent et c'est là nulle où
il va tenter non à la fois faire
l'adoption là pour jouer d'adoption
tourbe et trois quarts est listé trois
paraît logique hein c'est pas idiot
elle veut faire c6 c7 ses 8 ha ouais nan
époque et peut-être mal en fait tout
d'un coup c'est cette force est pourri
tient encore mais faudrait pas que la
tour blanche réussissent à à partir de
l'autre côté
en tout cas les peaux qui s'est fait un
peu dominés ils n'étaient pas forcément
vraiment moins bien avant s'il gagne pas
ça a plus aucun intérêt exactement
la photo l'adoption d'un an une fois
qu'on en est là s'il a pris ce chemin
sakhalinsk ya de l'intérêt droit f2
probablement et le roi qui contrôle bien
mais peut-être revenir en c2 avec la
tour pour menacer ses 7 et cavaliers des
six
c'est intéressant ça tour ces deux rois
f1 pourquoi pas à l'aîné peau
dans les quatre c4 mais bon sur tour ces
deux tours des 300 prend aux pions pas
mal joué mais là y'a pas toi
bref c'est tout reprend b5 le carrier
qui m'ont tu as roi c7
ça va être dur là pour danielian 3 pro 6
3 des 5 qui arrive ajoute ou tempo
maintenant dépôt c'est bien joué ça
reprend ses 6 pi et prend des quatre
nippons qui sut est le pion qui part
fait un échec qui voulait faire tomber
clairement et elle est tombée et ça y
est c'est sale
il y avait cavaliers prend des quatre
échecs là dessus et c'était fini mais
elle est tombée il fait une petite
grimace parce qu'il y avait la
découverte et voilà 10-0 l'adoption ce
qu'on appelle une adoption 10 0 bon bah
c'était l'intérêt du match les mecs et
c'était salins il a fait du sale nom là
c'était c'était sale
elle était mieux en plus mais bon ça
fait le disert alors ça fait mal 20-0
sais quoi mais je sais pas 20 0 c'est
rare un 20 0
mais je pense que 6 mai à fond il peut
le faire
ce que je veux sans intérêt non je sais
pas normalement c'est l'adoption le truc
ouais de base ont pensé qu'ils ont
failli jouer tranquille il n'a pas voulu
la jouer méchante je pense à mes juste
c'est trop facile
le t1 adoption c'est un terme
international herbache acerbes abacha
attention quand même un jeu j'utilise
des termes internationaux là si tu
connais pas c'est que tu vis dans une
grotte tout le monde connaît le mot
adoption ici j'imagine dans le chat ou
pas dites moi dans le tchat
vous connaissez quand même rennes st
terme quand même assez connu un air
bravache attention hein c'est que
charest qui utilisent n'aurait pas connu
de chasse bras c'est du connu avec le
truc d'hikaru contre contre en scène et
puis après c'est c'est resté
non mais c'est normal de se faire
adopter et va même un mec comme oms en
scène un peu se faire peut se faire
adopter par par un dépôt clairement
c'est des joueurs de très haut niveau
mais là il a il a peut-être
il a peut-être un peu baissé le live
fait vraiment vraiment attaquer ouais
c'est c'est l'équivalent de fanny
exactement en ce ne soit pas les vues
les adoptants bull est par contre contre
naka il peut se faire adopter à mon avis
hein
donc
la danielian kihal attaque quand même
allez
pour faire tourcoing f4 et j'étais en
train de me demander quel était le
tableau de maths pour les noirs ici à
beaucoup de pièces proches du roi
il faut réussir à organiser tout ça
maintenant pour les noirs je veux poser
la question est ce que cavalière trois
échecs quinn n'a quelque chose mais je
crois pas alors toute façon m dames pro
f 4
je sais pas 3h si c'est pour éviter les
problèmes avec la huitième rang g dames
g3 il va réussir à forcer les changes
des dames est il contre attaquera après
avec la tour sur la 7e
tours c'est cette qui va arriver on peut
pas partir avec la dame en réalité
puisque à la tour eiffe quatre ans
prises qui va les changer en h4
il fera peut-être un petit coup droit et
fin peut-être pas direct ce qui peut
laisser le pion h3 en l'air j'en fais
retour c'est cette non non il cavaliere
3 aussi qu'ils traîneront f1 c'est
important ouais ça rappelle la caq on
trouve ifan de l'an dernier mais
peut-être même en pire donc tour ses
huit l'idée c'est que si droit par an
achète y aura des fous eux 4 / tour f 5
janvier tu peux faire tour c4 ou tour 4
et yahia il ya toujours des fous prend
1,4 sur échec il va échanger une fois
maîtres latour ans et sait tout faire
fou prend 17 exactement
et maintenant ça fait un pion de plus et
ça va faire 11 0
les peaux qui chante on ne sait quoi
ouais c'est ça fait beaucoup et au kef
où price 3 gaffe en un et voilà niveau
qui fait des petites grimaces genre
quasiment désolé et là là ça fait
maintenant 11 0 le score qui enfle
le score qui enfle
oui et non c'est ça souligne quand même
les problèmes de règles du speech est ce
un match comme ça devrait être arrêtée
quand même assez à ça doit être arrêté
par ko quand on devrait dire oui tu n'as
tu as fait une commotion cérébrale tu ne
peux plus jouer c'est trop une procédure
de commotions cérébrales tu pars
larbitre gardes suisses encore jose
échec et il te dis bon tu ne peux plus
jouer c'est plus possible c'est trop
humiliant
mais pas d'un match cinq équipes rangées
ici cela en force
marc mais là c'est trop
non non il y en a pas le droit
d'abandonner à le blé d'aller jusqu'au
bout du match je trouve que c'est un peu
cruel pas médecin traitant qui est un
service de la prochain échiquier suvi
semaines doit le médecin traitant qui
est là en mode non sérieux tu peux pas
ouais sérieuses et c'est un peu exagéré
donc là il faut voir un pur n'est point
ça peut être un objectif de monter la
tour je pensais apprendre d'eux des plus
tôt ouais c'est mine espions faible ici
attaqué le roi non mais là ya pas de
remonte à da qui traîne un qui tiennent
ya rien là là j'ai envie de te dire
c'est vraiment là comme si au foot il y
avait à l'est par 11 0 mais c'est à 6 ou
7 0 et qui reste trente minutes à jouer
il n'y avait pas d'un match plein qu'il
faut pour acheter demain nancy fait fou
prend h7 roi prend il y aura sur roy g8
après t'as pas de cavalier qui arrive en
g5 et d'un match 5-3 g8 palmarès de la
dame g2 un échec quoi
j'ai pu entendre de café motivation n'en
avons la c1 c'est long je sais pas au
niveau des commentaires ce que ça donne
puisque même a commenté je vous cache
pas c'est un peu long il n'y a vraiment
aucun intérêt de quoi que ce soit il ya
trop grosse différence mais moi à la
place de danielian je pense que je rage
quit à un moment donné c'est je sais pas
comment il fait pour rester concentré
comme sa fin juste eu je te fais l'avait
quoi après un truc comme ça tu te dis
qu'est ces jolies cuisses et de suite
dit ouais face et c'est trop quoi je
parle cette dame de france et deux sur
échec
les dames elles devraient donc tu vas
avoir gagné un pion dans la sphère
by jouets sont très contraignants mais
je suis admiratif fab parce que moi je
me fais défoncer comme ça enfin j'ai
même plus envie de jouer en fait face ça
sert à quoi
pas un même pendant trois jours j'ai
plus envie de jouer aux échecs
enfin je dis oui fâcheux sert à quoi fin
je sais que je me ferais des fonds c'est
pareil mais je suis ok tu en prends mon
0 en gros tu as passé toute ta vie a
joint un truc et le mec qui te défonces
mais comme si tu étais enfin c'est
horrible en fait juste psychologiquement
c'est horrible et il force même pas un
cerf qui tu es 11 0 mais genre il il a
vraiment pas très bien joué pour pour
son niveau d'il ya plusieurs parties il
a raté des trucs ses joueurs avec mes 11
0 c'est en marchant qua non n'en prend
pas nécessairement plus qu'on se joue
compte des plus forts fallait-il ou par
là c'est pas jouer là ce que ça
s'appelle c'est une mise à mort en fait
c'est juste c'est passé c'est vraiment
violent je trouve elle se bat vraiment
bien ça c'est vraiment vraiment un
compliment
ouais c'est un cabaret sauvage
gm libye ça elle va peut-être tenir
non mais tu peux pas te tu peux pas
détacher du résultat face à un moment
donné qui a peut-être faire nul à l'est
a enfin enfin
enfin denis province a tué tout
l'intérêt du match ça y est
n est pas il avait d'ailleurs mais paul
est il vous trouvez il joue vraiment
tranquille 1 n'est pas fini par faire
non mais il s'en est peut-être qu'il
s'est quand même dit que m 30-0 c'était
trop et dupouy face à un moment moi je
trouve qu'il a baissé le rythme
non mais bon
ça va ça fait du bien ça fait du bien
ce passage fait gagner c'est que joueur
il joua sa main jouée à saigon il doit
être un peu jet lag d'aussi part par la
sinne que phil cap chez pas quand il est
rentré mais ça à faire maximum de trois
jours qu'il est rentré ouais je vais
tenir encore une heure après on fait pas
du commentaire de foot à 1 voire homard
qu'on parle de ça et là c'est pas c'est
pas si mal on se passe une petite aprem
sympa après honnêtement je vous le dis
franchement de voir ça ou de faire des
parties contre vous je préférerais de
match d'aujourd'hui on va on va pas se
mentir je préfèrerais jouer contre vous
c'est pas l'impression de regarder un
gamin se faire taper dans une cour de
récré tu vois j'ai l'impression d'avoir
d'avoir jean-charles danielian contre
contre momo karim et
et et amine du 9-2 tu vois qu'ils sont
venus s'amuser un peu sur paname dans le
8e arrondissement tu vois ce que j'ai
envie de te dire
et là si tu veux aux lieux qu'une
intervention de la police daniel wrench
la non si tu veux des rfi non vous avez
trois heures les mecs et du cou et du
coup tu comprends que que le goûter de
changeurs de jean-charles il va il va
passer à la trappe quoi tu sens que ça
va pas le faire tu sens que sa veste
il va y va la perdre et que avec
l'argent de poche il va y passer
tu as l'âge un pont entre en train de
suivre ça messieurs c'est dans un monde
où il ya c'est mad max si tu veux c'est
qu'il n'y a plus de police ya plus rien
c'est à 3h quoi et tu es mal
donc c'est un peu ce qu'on est en train
de regarder en tant que spectateur je me
sens un peu voyeuriste sadique si tu
veux cgc a c'est un mélange se fait un
peu mal à l'aise parce que je suis en
train de voir
c'est comme quand tu vas des sites sur
des sites 18 plus il ya des vidéos tos
pas les ouvrir tu dis non
si je commence à ouvrir ça je glisse
enfin vous voyez de quoi je veux parler
voilà donc ça voilà faut le savoir tu
dis là non là c'est non c'est pas pour
moi j'ai pas le droit mais si bordel je
droit non tu ça tu dois pas l'ouvrir
c'est un peu ce qu'on est en train de
regarder en fait là si vous voulez c'est
on est dans des trucs c'est c'est ccc du
moche quoi doit à ces trucs
ouais tu souffler un peu quoi
ouais non là c'est vrai ces interdits
aux moins de 18 ans mais même moins de
21 là si tu veux moins de 18 ans ont dit
non 19en on ne regarde pas dégager ma
part c'est vraiment sale c'est pas tabou
et c'est pas guéri qu'avec le résultat
et c'est secondaire ouais mais là non
faite sur la situation au niveau du
résultat ou c'est plus secondaires un
moment donné l'as lattes as tu as
l'impression que tu as l'impression que
c'est tu voyais quand il dit je te
défonce essai qui a défoncé de stargate
tu vois c'est à dire que là c'est
vraiment la ccc tellement violent
puissant et j'ai envie de dire répétitif
que là c'est c'est ses portes ouvertes
soit ces journées portes ouvertes c'est
fini on est mal les mecs
bon on va recommencer a fini champion
placer un truc et cavaliers b5 mais
vraiment ça marche pas parce qu'il ya
une déviation de tours france est un
jusqu'à inclure qu'un internaute ans a
commencé sur le jeu oui mais du coup on
fait le jeu a plus trop d'intérêts non
plus vu que le score effet l'objectif
d'un match c'est quand même de le gagner
évidemment si t'as perdu t'as perdu au
fin fond là à l'époque il se refait
planté un petit truc bon mais il va
gagner tranquille ouais c'est c'est
quasiment mode dark knight où allaient
tomber au moins s'est fait non plus aux
rixes séparant des grandes parties quoi
ça finit souvent par un dépôt qui fait
rien de spécial en plus un franchement
alors ils partent tous est tombé
complètement insipide où il s'est rien
passé des sex-shops d'exceptionnel donc
ok c'était des belles parties qui a des
belles combinaisons et tous je dis pas
sylvain je suis d'accord avec toi
d'ailleurs mais là en fait les parties
en soit c'est que des trucs hyper solide
du côté danielian pour pas perdre vite
mais pau qui s'en voit pas en l'air qui
vous tranquille aussi là tant qu'elle
tombe
pas gères-tu parce que l'occident quand
on reçoit un nouveau joueur dans un cas
elle surtout pas que cela se passe comme
cela se calme à leur nom souvent sinon
on ne revoit plus jamais le nouveau
joueur qui a osé pousser la porte du
club bar l acea
c'est un peu ça ouais non métro jansky
je me serais fait défoncer pareil par un
dépôt clairement un nom mois ce qui ce
qui m'étonne positivement celle avec la
combativité de danielian parce que
franchement moi je suis tellement dans
le mal j'aurais déjà pété des trucs là
chez moi et j'aurais rage quit
honnêtement j'aurais rage quit à un
moment donné où j'aurai commencé à jouer
plus offensif essayé d'envoyer faire des
belles parties faire quelque chose mais
j'aurais pas contre continue à jouer des
trucs aussi insipide pendant jeu
j'aurais pas pu en fait j'aurais pas pu
continuer à jouer sérieux
george aurait pas eu je n'aurai pas la
force en fait
annoncée
non mais j'aurais sûrement perdu pareil
quand j'avais fait la finale de l'aréna
les une fois je m'étais fait défoncer ya
une fois je m'étais fait défonce grave
j'avais dû faire deux ennemis sur 15 ou
un truc comme ça ou sur cèze j'en
pouvais plus mais je pouvais juste plus
jouer aux échecs à un moment donné a
vraiment pourquoi j'ai fait le match
contre kamski en six parties j'avais
perdu fin il y avait deux et demi deux
ans et demi j'avais perdu trois et demi
deux ans et demi c'était un peu chaud
après kamski moins fort qu'au dépôt mais
c'était pas je m'étais pas fait humilier
ça dépend ça veut rien dire je reste
plus juste pour le tchad bah écoute
merci pour la communauté j'ai envie de
dire on essaye de ont fait ce qu on peut
hein
le match de vendredi sera plus
intéressant j'ai juste vérifier qu'ils
jouent vendredi parce que j'ai les jeux
doit avoir
à
[Musique]
je suis en train de chercher je suis en
train de chercher le prochain match pour
être bien sûr
[Musique]
genre à chercher
en train de chercher par macha mais je
trouve pas je suis rentré je le
regardais sur check point com
il doit y avoir les dates je crois que
c'est guy quelque chose voyez du 11
juillet c'est la première page switch
est un qui amène autant de monde parce
que le match est vraiment temps des
idées ou calendrier où est-ce qu'ils ont
foutu le calendrier c'est pas possible
voilà qu'est ce que c'est que ça quand
j'arrive plus à le trouver
ouais 6 septembre et c'est ça sur ordi
tu as eu plus de facilités aux équipes
duda contre contre guiry ça doit être à
19 heures quid au 555 donc c'est sympa
elle va encore tomber à la pendule je
pense
pour la position et papa pas si clair le
pion à efforts quand même hein mais bon
là ainsi le pion à et fort wayne en
doute aguerris ce sera un match sympa
clairement duda guérissa être un match
très sympa
donc ça fait treize fois ça fait 13 0 en
fait un an et demi point on les compte
pas un taff et 13,0 ce qui est incertain
un certain score ouais les 23 4 heures
moi je trouve qu'elle a bien joué 1 pour
son lots 23,81 la cam éliminer des
joueuses très très fort ça va très bien
joué on la revoyait pas du tout à ce
niveau elle s'est qualifié via le
qualifia fire donc elle s'est qualifiée
parmi toutes les filles allaient aller
passer par les qualifs pour gagner le
speech est féminin elle a vraiment bien
joué
pour en arriver là
mais là du coup après avoir gagner
gagner gagner elle se retrouve face à
plus forte qu'elle donc là c'est une
structure de type karo kann avec la
paire de fou pour les blancs est ce que
firent outrage ou ce speech s oui je
crois qu'il ya un premier tour contre
aronian premier tour qui sera
intéressant mais hier du speechless
juniors on a vu huy qui s'est bien fait
bien fait l'avait aussi à part mvl qui
était qui était quand même assez facile
tout ça pour dire que déploie encore une
énorme marge pourrait jouer contre un
joueur qui a 300 points de plus que
danielian et gagné assez facilement tout
cas difficile 1
difficile
le pouvoir peut être partir en c1 une
nouvelle fois en d2 j'aurais plutôt vu
oui parce que peut-être faire des trois
c4 arrive ce qui est des saints qui fait
à trois pouces et 1 et maintenant il va
jouer sur les droits
il va peut-être jouer avec h 4 h 5 et
tour h1 s'il peut elle a commencé à
accélérer des points il lui reste deux
minutes 54 à l'hélice bar à lait juste
partie façon il a le temps il peut
revenir dans une minute ou deux j'ai
envie de te dire à l'aise 3
touré casse à faire j'ai quatre par la
suite il va progresser alors à carreaux
cannes
il réussit vraiment à mettre ce qu'il
faut contre la carro cannes les deux
fous bien placé l'el dame bien vissé fou
g5 bien joué je suis raciste est il
repart il aura un peu affaibli tour 17
g4 quand même se demander si ces quatre
pouvait devenir une option pour jouer
sur sur les tours mais bon pourquoi pas
j'ai quatre plus de 35 secondes pour
danielian il y en qui est dans le malin
[Musique]
cette fois c'est un peu abusé
embraer
et dame je dirais c'est bien jouer le
roi jean dame j'ai deux là pour libérer
la case g2 est attaqué sur la colonne g
bon
phocéen il menace le pion g6 protéger et
h5 qui on prend qui marche pas il n'y a
jamais deux fois je suis ça couvre il va
préparer fou à 2 du coup ça c'est bien
joué encore cavaliers b6 pour caillasser
cap est peut-être là du tour des huit
tours f8 et h5 qui va rôder 5 qui arrive
maintenant et tour g55 avec la tour en
des huit ça fait un peu peur tête du x x
2k et c4 tient tout pour le moment
tourcoing f5 tout reprend f5 fou prend à
j-6 prise h si ces prises le quart
étoile ça va gagner c'est sa prise le 4
est prise à j-6 maintenant sur fou prend
il ya dame g8 maths en un dépôt qui
joues pas tu aimes paul matte en main et
danielian qui abandonnent avant qu avant
que les peaux le vois aller ça fait
quatorze 14 0 donc une enseigne aux
stéréotypes de genre non c'est pas c'est
pas moi c'est pour alice rim jeu soit
bon
14-0 c'est violent les parties
s'enchaînent système de londres
maintenant pour danielian parti qui
s'enchaînent et qui se ressemblent
finalement là c'est vraiment j'ai envie
de dire
la machine à laver n'est paulin l'aï
lave plus blanc que blanc
sevani chevannes ichn et pau c'est une
épaule n'y avait ni chuan et nenê poney
peau vanish tu mets tu y aller les
tâches ne restent pas là le tan le tas
ne tient plus si vous avez des tâches de
thann sur sur vos t-shirts le dépôt
vanish nettoie à la c'est marrant parce
que sur calais france et 4 il ya
cavaliers pros f4 qui est pro b 6 qui
éprouvent eux deux et qu'il prend un
anglais produit et qui est pro
j'hallucine moi même pardon pardon
monsieur propre sueur et face à la coupe
de cheveux donné peau monsieur propre
qui sut du crâne par mais c'est génial
n'est pas née peau qui à mon avis juste
en jouant je pense qu'en réalité il a
déjà gagné le match en juste en jouant
en fait juste s'ils jouent des coups pas
mathématiquement en cas de déconnexion
ou à ou de problèmes de ce type là mais
sinon je pense quand même juste en
jouant des coûts et en perdant on y met
en images il fut 40 coups par parti je
pense c'est quasi gagné déjà voir
complètement gagné nancy s'est
complètement gagné en fait c'est fou
quand même pendant la panne ayant acquis
une position correcte
qui a réussi à tenir donc
donc donc
4 doit rester par en 14 parties ben
ouais pas loin mais je pense que c'est
déjà bon à peine 13
je pense que c'est déjà je pense que
c'est déjà bon
donc même pas lui ont collé une si elle
va en gagner une à un moment donné je
pense c'est un peu le suspense qui
restent
c'est un peu le dernier suspense c'est
vrai qu'il s'est tenu là il y aurait
ignoré qu'un zéro serait plus marrant et
ce soir on suivra pas gary les mecs
ce soir on suivra pas on sera pas gary
vous dit tout de suite et en a marre il
y en a marre de regarder des massacres à
l'époque et que le meilleur conseil
qu'on lui donner c'est de s'asseoir sur
les mains pour pas joué de mauvais coups
j'ai envie de te dire c'est un conseil
que tu suis jamais quoi c'est comme un
peu spécial
donc daniel inquiet peut-être pas si mal
le x 7 qui est bien bien bloqué dans les
pionts elle puis on a cinq qui est bien
avancé
oui fans qui avaient perdu 27 ans et
demi né peau qui peut faire mieux
25 points d'écart ouais il peut faire
mieux
il faut qu'il s'applique un peu plus
donc là il veut tout reprend d un tour
prend des un es fou price trois
peut-être ya peut-être dame 17 salua al
2018 dans le tchat
ouais mais là peut-être tour à 8 à 7 et
dame me faire à cette tour des tours et
sète et là y'a pas fou pro f 3 adam
bessette ce pion à qui est fort 1 et à
tour des huit échecs aussi sur fouet f3
c'est pas sûr adam 1 à adam un ces
salles qui est peut-être souffert dame
b6 et pousse ses pions quand même ouais
je pense ou faire dame b6 a laissé jouer
alors comment est ce qui peut récupérer
le pion d'un médium menace supra f3
ça a l'air d'aller
le fou est mal placé il est complètement
bloquée dans la chaîne de pionsat c'est
intéressant et faire dame ces deux rois
g1 d'amener un rush de damas deux rois
j'ai un bep kata 7 des trois dames 17 b
2 ouais ça va gagner autant prêt je
crois d'un bandama 2b 4 b 3 il est parti
pour le faire et ça a gagné autant prêt
ça permettait d'échanger les pions et de
gagner et de gagner avec la pièce de
plus allez ça fait plus 15 soit si c'est
sûr que c'est gagner mathématiquement
puisque encore une partie qui s'est
terminée qui a été longue
et donc 1 0 15 0 15 0
c'est incroyable un 15 0
quand on y pense le score est lourd
attention là pas se faire petit rock
avec les noirs y aurait dame proche sept
matches je crois que j'ai déjà vu cette
position quelque part c'est une partie
bacrot gharamian qui ressemble à ça
en tout cas c'est le score qu'on pensait
au début du match et on voit quand même
l'énorme différence entre des grands
maîtres de premier plan et des joueurs
d'un bon niveau après un mais mais mais
qui sont loin du top mondial
il ya vraiment une énorme différence que
l'on peut constater ici
qui va refaire un peu comme tout à
l'heure un rouage et 2h 4h 5 cd plan
classique
on va voir
prendre de l'espace attaques à l'endroit
faut essayer de jouer à ces cinq rapide
là pour les noirs dès qu'on peut c'est
jouer immédiatement gens préfèrent dame
prend
case difficile 1
mais oui je pense que les championnats
demix ça ça permet ça permet une mg une
émulation et de jouer mieux parce que du
coup le message qu'ils envoyaient c'est
qu'il faut travailler plus pour réussir
et je pense que ça peut qu'être un
message positif
ah non là complète de haut niveau bas
baume c'est tout à fait différent les
mecs sont dans une autre galaxie
mais je pense en revanche rsa peut être
que bénéfique pour pour les échecs
féminin ce genre de compétition
c'est aimer vous faudra qu'ils
pourraient plus qu'être compétitions
féminines du coup pour pour te forcer à
dire voilà pour réussir il faut arriver
à 2700 l'émulation c'est hyper important
donc ça pourrait créer une émulation et
dire ok si témoin de 2007 tu ne fais pas
partie du haut niveau et ça te force à
travailler plus plus plus plus pour y
arriver
et peut-être que comme ça en réalité tu
augmentes le niveau tout le monde je
pense que c'est important
y'a qu'a voir généralement dans les pays
forts aux échecs qui a plus de bons
joueurs parce que ça crée une émulation
c'est normal mais c'est un peu pareil
avec les échecs féminin je pense que
finalement il ya du positif mais il ya
aussi du négatif et sa force pas à se
dépasser pour pour arriver au top
mais je dois dire que daniel yon n'y a
pas beaucoup elle réussit quand même à
pas mal et c'est joué solide 1 quand
même ouais comme l'argentine au fort
nelson mais l'argentine au fournisseur
du coup ils jouent plus des nations
pourri ça qui est important c'est que
faut faire les deux si tu veux vraiment
lancer un truc à mon avis il faut en
parallèle aussi supprimer les échecs
féminin foot est vraiment le message ok
maintenant maintenant tes dents voilà tu
joues avec les autres et c'est tout
enfin soit arrive suite mieux au niveau
soit a soit tu dégages
mais ça ça peut ça ça te force est bon
et ça crée une vraie émulation qu'il
faut c'est ça qui l'avait pas vue dépôts
clairement il avait raté la rate et fou
à 7
elle voulait forcer dame prend pour
aller faire des échecs en f3 j'imagine
mais elle a raté fourrage cet échec et
tour h4 et tour des quatre pardon de 5
bien jouer encore mesdames détroit et
tours détours prendre 5 bien jouer les
potiches vraiment bien la tour des six
tours ses katas oui ok il veut garder la
protection là peut-être tout reprend h 5
tours prend aussi sa à puis on prend
tour c'est cet échec et il pense que
cette finale là est simple à gagner
c'est pas sûr il s'est peut-être plan il
s'est planté dépôt mais j'ai aussi les
amis joueuse d'échecs qui m'ont dit
qu'elle faisait mais la séparation
actuelle facilement des priori mais bon
du coup c'est du sexisme dans l'autre
sens quoi hélas le va tenir et faire
annuler ce que ça encourage de sexisme
du coup c'est une autre forme
je sais pas comment ça s'appelle mais du
coup misogynie c'est pas le bon mot mais
mais mais du coup en quelque sorte
qu'elle est moche je pense qu'il va
essayer de monter le roi vers la bas
tu ne sais pas quand même monté droit il
va gagner en fait en vrai il cache le
roi
ok là c'est bien joué de la part de
danielian époque il ya peut-être un peu
déconné encore
wen et pau qui amèneront à 2 fallait
plutôt monter vers les plans adverses
peut-être et il fait nul et ben voilà un
deuxième demi point on peut qui pèche un
peu par des concentrations aussi et
c'est tant mieux
donc
enfin qui vous fait peur on y avait un
père pète fruste you qui est bouffé les
pions car dans une petite slave
l'espoir renaît exactement ce que si je
m'habille souvent payants sur soi la
notice par mais le oui mais pas pas
comme ça ouais sur une grosse des
connexions je sais pas ce qui se
passerait
ce avec les partis qui partent pas dans
n'importe quoi serait-ce hyper solide
j'ai cinq et il va y avoir un plan
peut-être pour amener le cavalier vers
régis
massi qui met la pression sur ses 4 cyl
florian f1 il y aura peut être des
problèmes sur g4 jesse est la boucherie
india et nkt à ce cadre a plus de chance
un [ __ ] alors peut-être qu'elle a plus
de chance de gagner une partie ouais
encore que honnêtement je sais pas
honnêtement je sais pas
nip ok bon en bullet mais après il est
vraiment taillé vraiment en première
vitesse là
donc
on va voir mais là n'est pas une
nouvelle fois un qui qui se met mal dame
f5 là c'est fort car elle est riche
c'est donc is her say dans l'ue à la
tête un coup comme roy b1 peut être
intéressant pour avoir des cavaliers
prend des 5 et plus avoir du fou prend
b2 sur échec h4 aussi bien joué
donc chasse la dame la lame pierre
parent ces deux têtes il va réussir à
faire grand roc comme ça sur fion
pranger 5e cavaliers pranger 5
donc il reste quatre dans cette cadence
il reste peut-être deux parties encore
et danielian qui veut ouvrir la position
pour favoriser sa paire de fou de bras
qui s'est qualifié en gagnant un title
tuesday réside chez skf 6 et sur
cavaliers pranger 4 il doit y avoir
flash 3 pour jouer sur le clouage l'epo
qui est dans le dans le mal
elle est quand même très resserrée dam
des deux j'allais vous proposez c'est
super bien joué elle menace x 5
et puis on prend g5 voit l'année peau
qui ya une position assez désespérée et
désespérante
c'est pas trop comment il peut s'en
sortir j'ai vraiment mal
cavalia fuite
la fois à saint cloud prend des 8 mai
tête le jour un peu plus vite quand même
ce truc là non elle n'a pas vu à elle
avait elle n'avait pas vu fois à cinq
dames d2 c'était eux c'est un cours
formé par pure réussite ça reste
excellent pour les blancs
ma position dès lors qu'ils aient
vraiment l'époque il y aura vraiment été
mal tout le loin
non je pense pas qu'il s'en sorte je
pense pas que nepos en sorte
voilà la position elle est
catastrophique
je vois pas comment il peut sauver sa
donc j'avais prévu qu'ils lâchent un peu
de des game personnellement comme ça là
mais je pensais qu'il en lâcherait plus
qui serait moins consistants encore que
ça là il n'a pas encore perdu un il n'a
pas encore perdu celle là s'ils
récupèrent le pion aux 5
ça peut revenir chaud parce que la dame
est sa qu'elle contrôle g7 et elle
bloque un peu les pions maintenant il va
falloir voir comment ils poussent de son
côté pour pour savoir si réussie à a
volé cette partie quel calcul il fait
des 3g cette tour des 6 g 6e tour des
six il reste malin
à akébé 3 ça n'avait pas vu et il arrête
les pions de justesse ou pas non hossa
gagne pour les blancs g7-g8 imparable
enfin ça ça gagne facile
enfin une victoire de danielian à elle
sera pas fanny et ben voila note une
note positive mais je pense normalement
que la partie devrait être arrêtée celle
là non il n'y a plus de parti en trois
plus un parti interrompu à et ben voilà
ça fait plaise les mecs une victoire
mais pauvre finalement puni néo pop unis
et c'est tant mieux ça fait du bien
cette petite cette petite victoire de
danielian pour pas finir à 0
allez on va on va filer vers la pause et
on se retrouve très bientôt
pendant six petites minutes
à
[Musique]
les mecs on est de retour enfin on est
de retour je suis de retour plutôt pour
la deuxième dernière phase du speech est
ce le 1 + 1 et est donc ça va ça va
partir ça à partir pour le un plus un ça
va être du lourd
n'hésitez pas si vous êtes nouveau sur
sur le stream à mettre un petit polo sur
la chaîne vous avez aussi les chaînes en
dessous de nos streamer partenaires dont
bon moi même bon pourquoi pas j'ai envie
de te dire mais surtout maxime vachier
lagrave numéro un français qui stream
qui serait lui aussi sur une chaise
comme sur sa chaîne twitch switch point
tv slash mvl chess donc il va nous
rester une une petite demi heure de
match en plus un et on va voir ce que ça
donne
nouvelles personnes aujourd'hui qui ont
follow la chaîne merci à vous merci à
kariat 9 qui vient de faux la chaîne
merci tonton tu fais plaisir et ce qui
serait même veine n'ont pas pas
maintenant mais il lui arrive de stries
vais aller on est reparti pour cette
dernière série donc 2 1 + 1 le score 16
quand danielian qui est un petit peu
revenu enfin pas dire qu'à limiter la
casse elle a perdu 9 9 0 en 5 + 1 et 7 2
en 3 + 1 alors est ce qu'elle va pouvoir
faire mieux en bullet écoute on va voir
ça je remette le son pour avoir les
cookies qui bouge donc à 30 minutes
maintenant 2 1 + 1 et ce sera la
dernière
le dernier segment du match donc en gros
on va avoir une dizaine de partis
peut-être un peu plus d'être un peu
moins peut en avoir 11 12 on peut en
avoir huit 7,8 aussi si jamais elles
sont vraiment très longue ce qui est
rare mais met donc le sort du match est
déjà bien évidemment pillés et on va
voir juste ce que ce que ça donne mais
pau qui jouent tous tempo danielian qui
joue pas mal elle joue toujours les
mêmes positions ans et c'est un style
assez
j'ai envie de dire c'est c'est un peu un
peu tristounet mais les joues bien
marque mais aussi jouant plus sur la
même position mais bon je sais ya
parfois de vrais trucs un peu un peu
c'est un peu de varier mais c'est
vraiment solide solide pas écouter
chacun son style en tout cas elle elle
se prend rarement de tactique
elle joue très solide
solide sur les appuis armés de brosses
en octogone il se fait il se fait manger
1,27 à 2
record à battre ouais mais je pense pas
qu'ils battent le record danielian
résistera mieux que willy fans face à na
kham enac n'est peau
née power est peut-être moins méchant
que d'un cas il fait il fait 3 fois on
pourra d'oberhof c'est vrai c'est vrai
devra les faire un régime
du coup
cette finale m'ont toujours mieux pour
les blancs grâce à la paire de fumay
mais il faut encore la gagne et non un
haka est un mec marrant mais pour les
échecs il un peu méchant kouassi si peu
de mettre 30 08 mai 30 0
une époque qui arrive pas à percer
bandonéon qui est vraiment très solide 1
c'est comme ça qu'elle avait réussi à
faire craquer katyal haguenau et autres
en jouant de manière très solide
menaka s'il peut aussi peut faire mal il
fait mal la danse bullet hell tient bien
n'est pas qu'il réussit pas à faire la
différence nous avait dit qu'en bull est
il allé il allait lui faire mal pour le
moment ce n'est pas le cas il faut
pulvériser son adversaire non oui bombe
en quelque sorte la wii il ya ya 14
points d'écart
la partie qui est longue la partie qui
dure qui dure plus de quatre minutes
déjà est là il commence à progresser ça
y est il est rentré avec le roi et il a
gagné autant mais il aura mis le temps
donc il passe à 15 points d'avance il
passe à 15 points d'avance il repasse à
15 points d'avance en fait même en cas
de déconnexion il va très bientôt avoir
gagné le match dans une dizaine de
minutes normalement il peut partir et le
match sera gagné
quinze secondes avant cela il peut il
peut jouer encore 10 minutes et se
barrer
son cassis
non les deux profs qui a fait pire il a
écrit il a écrit une lettre accusatoire
carrément sur des forums etc
donc c'est complètement différent mais
bon il s'est calmé depuis s'est rendu
compte qu'il avait tort peut-être
peut-être pas mais c'est bien pierre
d'être accusatrice war et autres caby
perlon racontant n'importe quoi mais bon
ce qu'il n'a pas apprécié de perdre
contre la grotte parfois ça arrive ça
arrive même on n'est pas allé l'accusé
de quoi que ce soit quand il a gagné le
title tuesday pour se qualifier aux
pitch est ce n'est pas allé faire des
lettres
on ne sait pas je ne sais pas je ne sais
pas l'armée il était clean n'y a pas de
souci mais améliore par l'ajustement
n'est pas on n'est pas allé faire de
lettres de quoi que ce soit je l'aï fait
son trou en effet son tour en effet ce
qu'il veut il a joué tout à fait
correctement il est capable de gagner un
title tune et il n'y a pas de y'a pas de
soucis c'est un bon grand maître il est
bon en blitz
donc c'est c'est quelque chose qui est
tout à fait dans le domaine du tri
possible mais bon
lui se serait permis d'écrire une petite
lettre donc ni peau qui est pas si bien
une nouvelle fois
née peau qui est passé bien une nouvelle
fois
maintenant ça va donc et c'est à lui à
l'ofce donc il ya une nouvelle fois
autant mais on voit pas des partis
franchement on voit pas de l'epo
vraiment dominé les parties jeu j'ai du
mal à comprendre fat duck août à une
explication là dessus comment comment ça
se fait entre guillemets que que daniel
ans résiste aussi bien en milieu de jeu
à un joueur comme nebo est-ce que
qu'est-ce qui est une raison
[Musique]
alberton tout y est mais bon elle tient
avec les noirs aussi un est ce que je
pense c'est parce que c'est parce qu'il
joue tranquille
ouais mais blindés blindé avec les
blancs les blancs d'accord tu peux mais
blindé avec les noirs c'est plusieurs
quand même
oui qu'est l'amérique ne sait pas jouer
oui c'est probablement une bonne
explication fabien je suis très heureux
de cette explication bien ce que je
pensais il montre son vrai niveau
donc à 16 points d'écart et j'essaye de
choper l'info de savoir en fait j'ai vu
je vois des infos contradictoires qui me
disent qu'ils aient un match demain au
kenya pas de match de demain c'est bien
ça demain y'a pas de match prochains
matchs vendredi salaire et il s'essaie
au pire il va pas faire non mais tu vois
je pense que je me ferais plus
massacrées par nippon en bullet que ça
alors qu'elle est 24,40 donc je veux
dire elle se bat vraiment bien en match
quoi surtout après m'être faire autant
défoncer au score en général j'aurais je
sais pas je me ferais massacre et je
trouve qu'elle défend bien
donc encore un point pour n'est pas
encore une victoire autant 17 points
d'écart on voit une hollandaise
maintenant à un grand biz stone town est
il a fait cas et f6 est très solide
mentalement elle est très solide
mentalement donc pour un 3 0 en bullet
il reste 19 minutes ouais donc ça peut
être un match à 9,10 bullet ouais c'est
bien ce que j'veux bien ce que je
pensais wen en lui-même en réfléchissant
plus il faut vraiment réussir à blinder
c'est pas si simple hein c'est pas si
simple de blindés mais elle plainte bien
une qualité c'est à des problèmes de
portes chez vous n'hésitez pas à faire
appel à danielian spécialiste en
blindage lecavalier 4 qui commence à
venir titiller un peu des trucs
donc il reste 30 secondes chacun blanc
qui aura une bonne position a je pense
tout cas elle fait ce qu'elle peut
kébé 5 elle va peut-être la gagner mais
c'est c'est beau quand même de gagner
partie en bullet contre contre né peut s
qui elle fait prend f4f ou prend f3 d'un
printemps et pas à temps je vais mettre
leur lord y avait pas y avait pas foule
pour un f4
il ya une pure f2 qui tombait mais est
pas un truc à prendre dans un sens
précis la pré roi fuite
vas y avait bien fou prend bessette qui
gagnait tout d'après l'ordi
on met l'épaule à qui
qui est en train de tenter de réseauter
leroy laura matériellement là il en est
où
ça commence à être bien tourné peau il y
en aurait q p encore un pion pour qu'il
y en des huit yalta et des quatre ans
prises la dame et dame prend des quatre
maintenant et c'est fini allez plus 18
alors +18 il reste combien de temps à
jouer il reste dix agneaux est donc née
paula qui pourrait déjà un écho qui
pourrait déjà se barrer c'est un mec n'a
kahuna cas où ces camps illicites et 25
points d'écart non non non on fera pas
mieux que les 25 points d'écart on ne
pourra pas faire mieux que les 25 points
d'écart
il reste il reste six parties maximum là
les mecs
non non non là là enfin on fera pas un
record c'est ma fille qui n'a aucun
intérêt mais attendez pas en qu'on
discutait de sa est une dame qui est qui
a été perdu at en effet de voir comment
s'est passée à il a fait dames c'est un
tour français à l'accord palmarès
données pot énorme et ce quand je vous
dis qu'il est vraiment pas dedans il
n'est pas dedans
mais bon il va peut-être la gagne et
quand même parce que sa tête le show
fait d'avoir une dame de moins et pour
pas la perdre il va peut-être passer la
surmultipliée merci akagi lottin qui a
pris un abonnement de twitch prime pour
son deuxième mois d'abonnement merci
cabrita du coût des pauses avait fait
marrer d'abord une dame de moins et là
il a placé une petite double attaque des
familles ça le fait marrer
donc oui c'est là on le voit il y aurait
appuyé sur le champignon avec la dame de
moins ça le motive à gagner une partie
comme ça et donc ils repassent le niveau
supérieur
et ça fait tout de suite la diff quant à
25 c pour gagner un tempo sur sur la
tour pour éviter tout reprend ses cinq
ans comment ça reste quand même
complètement gagnant pour les noirs
elle va quand même la gagner la tactique
n'était pas assez efficace que ça
cavalier f5
il veut créer un nouvel atout rang b 5
il veut créer un réseau et c'est encore
gagné pour les peaux malgré le drame
c'est un tour prend c'est juste pour
montrer pour pour voir la différence de
niveau 1 c mais bon on 3 me en bullet
contre 24 40 c'est énorme c'est énorme
donc 19 points d'écart
chérèque soucaille way c'est vraiment
théorique avec dans la trompe offs qui
ça existe donc life i lecavalier c4 mais
pour pour une pseudo activités après
puis on prend des cinq je pense qu'il
fait un peu la gueule quoi que leur a
peut-être des 3
on va voir qui régale à chaque fois
qu'elle perdrait baloud un moment ça
t'amuse 1 face à tamuz ça ne fait pas
tant que ça une façon d qui fait un truc
paktika elle a besoin de réfléchir 40
secondes
donc il a fait tomber la ive dame b 4
échecs et hop
et hop tous cavaliers la parité qui
prend ses 7es yassa emprise intercale
détroit il faut fc il ya aucune
découverte intéressante et il veut des
deux échecs
ouais donc il va se faire plein là il va
prendre prendre ici prendre
il va recoller un échec deux échecs
trois échecs prendre la tour
pas sûr que ce soit si bien ce qu'il a
fait mais bon il fait plaise et soissons
il est bien matériellement ce que fit
rouge a défoncé nespouls ambühl est pas
sûr donc la chanson problème c'est fou
prendre dame prend grand roc dames f5
échec
c'est ce qui fait que c'est pas si
simple
rhodes
ouais il s'est peut-être retrouver dans
une situation un peu compliquée mais où
il a trouvé le bon plan c c'est bien là
ce qu'il a fait mais il est peut-être
pas si bien bon après il a voulu se
marrer en donnant une dame
il va devoir jouer cette finale qui est
loin d'être top on va voir il va mettre
le ronde et 5 mai à ça doit faire nul ou
pas qui ont des trois rois d un je pense
re3 mais fou ici et j'ai peur de
froisser 3 maintenant bats pour ça que
je vais mettre l'euro en d1
parce que maintenant fou c'est un et des
deux voilà oui là il gagne même le pion
f4 et maintenant voilà tout prix là et
maintenant roi c2 c3 roi c1 c2 et c'est
fini ça fait encore un point ça fait 22
à 2 mais il joue vraiment honnête on y
joue tranquille 1 il la joue tranquille
20 points d'avance
il reste dix minutes à jouer donc il
resterait il faut une vie qui va
peut-être finir par en perdre une à 5 0
dans le bullet aura fait deux nuls une
défaite
non je crois pas que ce soit une
question de sourire ou zen 1 franchement
je pense pas que ce soit une question de
souris
bon alors cette position est celle ferro
qui va faire [ __ ] un système pos c'est
sûr elle joue solide une nouvelle fois
elle est vraiment très solide
les peaux qui n'arrive pas à attaquer ça
le fait marrer
c'était à faire ou à 8,3 et fuite
maintenant pour venir colmater la dame
qui revient par des trois rois et fuite
elle a l'air d'être assez bien là quand
même l'attak de dépôt qui est
complètement pipeau
peut-être qu'il ya du cailly c2 qui est
prend des quatre là qui traîne je sais
pas j'ai fait qu'essayer avec
l'ordinateur c'est que des fois je me
dis ce que moi je vois plus rien non
plus où c'est les joueurs qui voient
plus fin et si ça marche ou pas bien sûr
ça marchait pas ce que dame f5
ouais bon après il aurait pu faire de la
preuve 5 mais il fait pas
donc et noir c'est encore complètement
gagnant mais voyez c'est ça qui me fait
dire que nespouls il joue vraiment
tranquille parce qu'il est perdant dans
quasiment toutes les parties maintenant
il va réussir à taper p7u va faire à
trois tours prend 17 à tous ces trois
bien joué et l'année peau qui est foutue
menace maths en 1 qu'elle défend bien là
il faut qu'il veut pas créer une seule
menace ou là elle a joué avec eux et à
faire ça et une nouvelle fois tombé il
vraiment pas bien et paulin 1 c mais ça
suffit pour gagner moi y avait des trucs
de partout et pantera fatalis là mais
bon il y avait des gardes partout on est
à 21 points d'écart d'ailleurs qui
continuent à se battre saint raphaël
fait pas elle fait pas comme on avait vu
petrosyan vous rappelez contre contre
magnus qui s'était qui avait fini en
paix à l'aise dans le noir qui avait
baissé qui avait fini comme ça ou à
envoyer plus que les cheveux elle à
l'époque et encore gagné il a gagné une
dame aller 22 points qui restent quand
même
souriante c'est tout à son honneur
l'écart ne fait que gonfler ses goûts
side of wealth était pas petrosyan
c'était gousseïnov petrosen et perdu
contre eux qui du coup ils avaient aussi
disparu de l'écran
ouais non c'est classe enfin wayne je
sais pas assez et j'avais tellement pas
être comme ça déjà faire cavalier aussi
penser qu'ils aient tenté encore 7,4 4,5
c'est encore 5 minutes 24 vert pour la
jouer arménienne qui pourra après
profité de sa soirée se reposer depuis
très longtemps à tenir à tenir donc et
qui arrive en d5 tu me prends des 5
allez encore un petit peu
non mais franchement c'est bien qu elle
résista à tenir mentalement comme ça
j'ai pas ça me parait ça me parait
inhumans d'être d'être aussi tranquille
c'est tant mieux
et c'est tant mieux on évoquait encore
on voit une qualité et doit rester trois
parties doit rester celle là et deux
derrière donc née peau qui peut faire au
maximum 27,2 donc réalisé le même score
que au mieux et réalisera le même score
que que naka qu'on trouve ifan et saïdia
française tarrach f1 il va il veut
couvrir son endroit
taterf 3g 4 à venir
mais nature en c4 se fout en dessin qui
vaut largement la qualité un retour des
trois pour chasser du feu cinq tours fkc
bien joué ça de la part de dépôt est fou
price est fou prend 1,5 et aussi ce
cette tour est fuite
allez un p'tit coup de 7 mois ya
peut-être plus fort ok fou prend il veut
faire damas trois échecs et tous rêvent
cette hausse est maintenant avec l'idée
de faire dame si ce soit ça gagne de
nouveau ça fait 8 0 en bullet to 9 0 ça
fait 8 c'est le score est bien à jour
ajout ce truc avec b5 que je joue aussi
parfois ça change un peu
donc je dirais c'est probablement la
dernière partie peut faire au maximum 26
2 il pourra s'en vouloir la partie qu'il
a perdues auraient pu faire 27 ans et
faire un record et il n'y arrivera pas
il fera pas une n'a qu'à uri fans
malheureusement pour lui pas loin de pas
loin d'y arriver mais mais il lui aura
manqué il aura manqué un peu de punch
il aurait été un peu un peu un peu mou
un peu facile niveau malheureusement en
tout cas j'espère que que ce match vous
a plu n'hésitez pas à faire des petits
retours là pendant la dernière partie et
on se retrouvera de toute façon après
demain je crois 19 à 18 18 heures du
coup je crois à 18 heures le match façon
suivez nous sur les réseaux sociaux vous
pouvez retrouver sur facebook et twitter
pour avoir tous les horaires je pas si
quelqu'un le avec quelqu'un qui avait
lié inter dans le tchat
on a été très solides quand même
la joueuse arménienne elle a été très
solide et donc là ça va être avec les
dessins qui passe est l'arrêt peut-être
il a le temps d'en faire encore une
série qu'elle a peu de temps la pendule
on peut la faire tomber en joue encore
une derrière cela sur les quatre qui a
éduqué et j non ça n'a pas marché
pas sûr qu'ils réussissent en fer qui
jca t rois aux deux dames e5 est
champion franges et katia dame prend aux
quatre pays qui va pas s'y rendre trois
dans sa marche pas donc f5
ils gagnent autant et il se donne la
possibilité d'en jouer une dernière je
crois qu'il ya juste le temps pour en
jouer une dernière et finir sur une
adoption donc faire une double adoption
allez donc ça joue pour pour 27 2 donc
qui battra pas quelque part le 27 et
demi à deux ans et demi et ça joue pour
le double adoption donc là il ya quand
même du il ya quand même de l'enjeu dans
cette partie alors qu'il n'existait pas
et donc l'article je vais moi aussi
ouvrir merci à à péron 23 ça me
permettent d'avoir la date exacte du
prochain match qui sera oui donc ce sera
vendredi à 18h vendredi 18h duda guiry
c'est une belle affiche
là c'est vraiment une belle affiche pour
la peine j'aurais personnellement pour
pour duda qui joue avec tout en pro che
sling mais on verra ce que ça donne en
tout cas c'est une vraiment une belle
affiche ce vendredi match à suivre serré
je pense que duda et est favori en
rapide mais qu'elle sera très
intéressant de suivre le match très très
clairement et envoyer du tour à trois
tours j'ai droit et à la fin du live si
vous souhaitez soutenir chess comme vous
pourrez
regardez les quelques pubs que je
passerai pouvez bien sûr follow la
chaîne ou faux le match n perso et celle
de m veltchev vous pouvez trouver tous
les liens en dessous si vous voulez
soutenir chess comme et les stream qu'on
fait en français et les compétitions qui
sont organisées par thiès comme ben
n'hésitez pas à laisser les c'est la pub
tournée et je vous enverrai un petit
raid après sur la chaîne officielle de
chess comme international ouais je pense
que tu penses que duda sera favori en
tout cas à tour qui va partir en g4 sa
menace pas vraiment tours angers 7 pour
le moment il le fait quand même il va
jouer avec la dame contre les tours
parce que le roi noir et mal à me 3 mai
dernier ils ont une nouvelle fois un qui
se défend bien
lv l'esu tu as gagné kevin au prochain
tour très chaud sow a montré de belles
de bonnes capacités l'année dernière en
finale contre nac a donc je serai pas
sur d'une victoire serait pas sûr du
tout d'une victoire
ça va être un match autant contre eux
oui ça allait autant contre sow c'est
plus du 100% du tout ce qui était
finaliste et qui a quand même mis en
danger
y a quand même mis son adversaire en
danger donc n'ont cessé c'est loin
d'être sûr c'est loin très loin d'être
sûr donc les tours qui vont perdre
il ya dames 6 6 dames c3 il n'y a pas de
maths l'année soit d'en prendre 5 et d 3
rebonds s'est complètement gagnant mais
ya pas de maths
la dame j'ai cinq matches ils arrivent
maintenant et donc 25 points d'écart
c'est chose faite
née peau qui peut être heureux de son
match bien joué de sa part
donc je vais vous m comme je vous disais
de la pub si vous souhaitez suivre on
sera de retour vendredi
demain soir il y aura un stream avec
l'arena francophone et je vous envoie le
raid dans six minutes merci d'avoir
suivi
ciao ciao
[Musique]